e
open for any amendments or changes uh Mr
chair I will abstain we weren't given
opportunity to re review the minutes
thank
you
the committee um of one thing and that
is the charge of this committee um and
so the charge of this committee as
outlined in 17616 DB Roman numeral one
is pretty clear it is hereby establish a
commission to study with the purpose of
proposing legislation of a state
controlled cannabis and cannabis
products right so understand we're not
here to discuss legalization we're
discussing how to put a bill forward
that would do legalization but do it in
a manner that is is most protective of
our citizens and and regulator and our
regulations so I I I want to be clear
that while I know we've had a lot of
discussion about legalization that
really isn't the charge of the
commission the charge of the commission
is to put the best Bill forward possible
if legalization were to happen in a
state controlled model and so what we
look when we're talking to um the
various speakers or ourselves again what
do we need to add to a bill to take care
of any concerns you may have about the
uh about legalization for our
citizens yes uh thank you Mr chair I
just want to put forth a reminder that
at our first meeting we agreed that we
would be hearing from um experts from
legalized states with the impact to
investigate issues on the impact of
those States also hear about the impact
on on the health and safety of Youth and
Young adults and the impact on Mental
Health right and again I think but but
again I I to to the charge of the
committee which is to put a bill forward
the goal is to take that information and
to make ours better than Colorado to
make our bill and our legalization
better than col that might have had an
issue and so it's what do we need to put
into the bill to make the bill better um
so that we don't have the issues that we
done in other
states study study commission and with
that I'll call up our first speaker um
doc Dr Omar
sha you please come up and turn the
microphone on introduce yourself that'd
be
great hi thank you so much for having me
here chair and members of the
committee my name is Omar Shaw I'm an
adult Child and Adolescent psychiatrist
and addiction medicine specialist I'm
currently full-time faculty at Boston
Children's Hospital and clinical
instructor of Psychiatry at Harvard
Medical School I work in the Adolescent
substance use and addiction program in
the division of addiction medicine at
Boston Children's Hospital which
provided more than 8,000 visits to the
young people and young adults with
substance use disorders last year I
personally have treated around 150
patients myself I'm familiar with the
New Hampshire legislature as I served as
a New Hampshire legislative Layon for
the New Hampshire Psychiatric Society
during my child psych training at
Dartmouth which ended in July 2022 I
currently serve on the Massachusetts
medical society's mental health and
addiction
committee I was ask by Katie to come
here uh to inform
deliberations rates of marijuana or
cannabis use among teens is at its
highest in three decades THC which is a
psychoactive chemical made by cannabis
plants is an addictive substance that is
particularly harmful to brain
development during the teen years while
many states have legalized cannabis
products products that contain THC
remain illegal by federal law therefore
the federal government does not Provide
support with regulation or oversight of
THC um based products as as it does does
for alcohol and nicotine regulation of
addictive products is complex and States
including New Hampshire lack the
infrastructure for doing so
appropriately at this time as a result
state-based legalization of cannabis
products exposes the population of the
state to Public Health harms THC impacts
many areas of the brain uh which are
important for almost everything
decision- making impulse control
emotional regulation pleasure perception
of time cognition and even physical
coordination there is a strong
association between use of canvas
products that contain THC and
psychiatric disorders most notably
psychotic disorders use of cannabis
products particularly during youth is
associated with poor functional outcomes
even in adulthood most notably it lowers
educational and ational achievement and
higher rates of mental health disorders
such as anxiety depression and psychosis
cannabis juice can also affect multiple
organs in our bodies like the lungs uh
cardiovascular system through the vaping
and smoking uh process uh also at Boston
Children's Hospital we have The Vaping
Clinic where we're seeing young adults
and teenagers for the first time uh
having issues with breathing shortness
of breath decreased exercise tolerance
when you look at their lungs um um uh to
the help of chest x-rays or CT scans you
see hyperinflated lungs um and and
consolidations which we normally see in
people with COPD and you know elderly
who've been smoking for
decades in Massachusetts where are
practice psychotic symptoms cannabis
hyperemesis syndrome and lung injury
from vaping have become increasingly
common in fact these conditions were
almost unheard of a decade ago I
personally have dealt with several
patients who have experienced I
conditions due to cannabis use in the
past decade many states legalized the
recreational use of cannabis for adults
21 and older while a Young Person's use
of cannabis remains illegal in all
states the new laws increase the
availability overall making the drugs
much more likely to land in the hands of
teens furthermore legalization makes it
confusing for teenagers when assessing
the safety of using uh cannabis one of
the most common questions for example I
get asked by my patients is is if
marijuana is so bad for you then why is
it becoming legal to use for uh every
everyone everywhere according to a study
published just this Thursday in the
Journal of addiction people who live in
the US states that legalized
recreational canus use uh they use Canal
up to 24% more frequently than those in
states where it's it remains illegal uh
the study also included 111 pairs of
twins and they um compared the twins who
live in legalized States versus the ones
who did not live in states where it's
legal and there was up to 20% of the
twins living in the states where it was
legalized were using cannabis uh this
leads to well documented evidence-based
risk factors concerning substance use in
teenagers this includes parental
substance use and and favorable or
permissive parental attitudes towards
cannbis and on the flip side uh
protective factors for the Youth include
parental disapproval and school
connectedness and I mention school
connectedness because we see this all
the time at the Children's Hospital
cannabis use is associated with poor
school performance um skipping classes
truy and low grades so we're often times
uh working with schools to address those
issues um a study published just last
week in the Journal of jamama network
open documented that some people with
pain anxiety or depression who obtain
medical marijuana cards overuse cannabis
and develop cannabis use disorder
failing to improve their symptoms um in
fact indeed 10% of them had developed a
disorder in just 12 weeks of getting or
obtaining the card and those figures
Rose to 20% uh if they were using it for
things like depression or anxiety and
lastly uh even CBD I've talked a lot
about THC but CBD also or can cannabid
is another chemical made by the cannabis
plant uh which we feel like is you know
the good part of cannabis is how we put
it right but the thing is there's little
regulation of CBD products and Studies
have found that many products are
mislabeled often containing less CBD
than uh they um than they label
themselves a recent study of 84 uh CBD
products purchased online found that
more than a quarter of the products
contain less CBD than labeled and THC
was found in 18 of them in high doses
even CBD can cause side effects such as
dry mouth diarrhea reduced appetite
drowsiness and fatigue and it can
interact with uh many medications
including blood thinners um perhaps most
concerningly the impact of CBD on the
developing brain has not been studied
and we simply don't know the exposure uh
that it has and and the impact it has on
children there's a major concern because
we know that the canono system which is
sort of like the natural marijuana in
our brain is very active in in guiding
brain growth and development throughout
childhood adolescence and even in young
adulthood while the risk of this
exposure May outweigh the benefits for
children with severe seizure disorders
uh you know we prescribe them epidex
which is FDA approved uh but the risk
benefit ratio May well be quite
different for children who don't have
these problems for these reasons I
recommend uh New Hampshire be cognition
of all these uh different impacts and
facts uh concerning cannabis while
making their decision on
future um legislature concerning um can
much thank you thank you Mr chairman
first of all Dr thank you very much for
coming um Dr we've heard uh when we we
legalize medical marijuana and we we say
that it could it could do something for
an individual that other medications
can't do kind of fill me in on on why
you think that's why that's the right
way or the wrong way to do it and and
why does it affect a person where other
medications keeps thank you so much for
that question so uh you know medical
marijuana is only so far approv for two
conditions one is severe intractable
seizures where no other medication works
and we're just trying to get these
people just stabilized so it's sort of I
can say emergency situations and then
the other situation where cannabis is
legalized is for people who are pretty
much have um a condition where they are
dying and they have pain and this is
something which could help them for
their pain uh while you know they're not
doing that well um so these are the only
two conditions where marijuana is
medically um loated approved and these
are FTA approved these medications such
as epidex right um the thing is once you
get away from these two conditions it's
very hard to see the benefits of
marijuana overall compared to the
potential side effects that it has and
that's why the medical community so far
overall uh large for the large part has
been uh very cautious when uh
prescribing medications and and when you
prescribe medications for recreation use
uh whether it be at alcohol stores or
any other stores it gives people the
wrong impression and uh and we're seeing
the impact of that on the youth in
Massachusetts where where I work right
now heard the question yeah thank you so
so if if all of this is present and if
we have a
scientific you know evidence that
says the negative the negative effects
appear What what is the factor that is
pushing the the other way what what is
the driving
force driving force for legalizing kind
of I mean this could be a matter of
opinion but I personally feel there's a
lot of uh Financial uh gains from this
which which which is what I see um and
and of course on on on the symptom side
of this a lot of patients do feel relief
when they use marijuana for anxiety and
depression however those it's sort of
like a Band-Aid it it it doesn't fix or
cure the problem it it you know you
you're intoxicated for a little while
you feel good for that particular period
of time and then it's over but the
underlying uh reasons you were using in
the first place like anxiety depression
uh they don't get better so that's why
we use other medications which are F
approved for such conditions and also
use therapy uh and there's various types
of therapy we use which have been shown
to benefit people with underlying
conditions such as anxiety and
depression and also unfortunately uh
cannabis is very highly associated with
psychotic disorders so I'm seeing a lot
of kids teenagers like 19 20 year olds
who have who have first uh break
episodes of um psychosis and and a lot
cannabis follow up again so now in your
role as a practicing physician how many
kids do you see that that have been
involved with with barel water or using
bar water quite
heavily you're seeing some of the
effects of this of the kids yeah so in
fact most of the kids I treat uh pretty
much use cannabis nicotine and cannabis
and even alcohol but especially nicotine
and cannabis are the most common uh
substances that kids are using actually
yep for sure more than 90% I would
say it just let me Edward just we were
we were given a con job about
cigarettes and for years you know it was
makes you feel good uh take take away
your anxiety and so forth and so on and
what did we get out of that cancer lung
cancer
pervasive a number of other situations
the body body parts fell apart we have a
settlement now with the tobacco industry
y uh and yet we're still
smoking problematic so you I'm glad you
brought that up actually uh Senator the
thing is that um just like you said so
for decades you know there's a lot of
financial gains you know cigarette
companies and were making a lot of money
and unfortunately it impacted Society in
a negative way for the most part and the
thing is that uh now those same
companies uh have I won't take any names
but the same companies are not targeting
the youth because uh you know almost
like they dos like why isn't up so now
there targeting the youth saying that
things like marketing Vapes vape pens as
benign and not really containing
nicotine and not very dangerous for you
it's kind of cool thing to do uh it's
just just water Vaped which is actually
not the case at all because now it's so
white spread it's an epidemic actually
we're seeing kids as I mentioned earlier
with lung issues which we never saw
before did this thing called evali or e
cigarette and vaping Associated lung
injury it's a new thing I I believe it
was coined back in 2019 not too far back
and that's where we see kids with
shortess of breath decreased exercise
tolerance coughing uh you know and and
the thing is that um I have a feeling
that once Society wakes up you know
maybe another 10 years vaping might be
banned that's just my opinion but who
knows but that's where we are right now
thank you than thank you sen so I have a
couple questions real quick so um
obviously the bill doesn't allow for
underage consumption right so 21 under
21 is illegal in the state in would be
illegal uh on the proposed bill so my
question comes is that early enough and
if not what's the what's the science
behind not doing it later than 21 if we
were to pick a different age and um Al
I'll startor with that I have a
follow-up question to that as well okay
no thank you so much for that so the
thing is what is you know 21 or even 24
the thing is once you legalize uh you
know substances like for example alcohol
has been legalized right and nicotine
right in the past so if you legalize
canvas you'll see the same impact that
the other substances have had on society
and the thing is that so most of the
kids that treat it's not like they're
getting marijuana through the doctors or
uh any such means they're getting it off
the streets and and and their main uh
logic is that Hey listen you know it's
legalized in Most states it's not a big
deal it's not like I'm doing cocaine or
or heroin so that's the way they
Justified and it just makes it e harder
and more more difficult for providers
such as myself and and many other
providers to provide treatment and we
have to sort of you know educate them on
the brain and we call it like the
neurobiology sessions at at Children's
Hospital where we educate them on the
brains and how substances affect them
and it takes time and a lot of these
kids do get better when they realize
what's going on but I feel like
legalization or even uh having it in the
market just for example like you you I
walk down in Mass Massachusetts I walk
down some very nice towns and there are
these nice stores like they look very
nice and have these vape pens in there
and cannabis and CBD and certain
products which will help relax you in
fact I feel like going and getting one
myself it's just so nicely marketed so
imagine kids right so that these are
just the concerns I have and and how do
we address this maybe like if it's if we
can have tests and done on these
products FDA takes a look at it
regulates them then maybe they can be
prescribed for certain conditions uh and
not just openly available in the market
thank you let me just have one more
followup question so I I'm I'm assuming
you would support if a legalization
model is to go forward given the
conditions you've just outlined you
would in support enhanced penalties for
the sale of marijuana to any kind of
juvenile any kind of minor you would
support enhanced penalties against the
retailer or the whoever's providing
it yeah I mean the reason I don't want
to uh I mean that could be the case but
I I also am a little little cautious
about the penalty part because the thing
is I've also seen the flip side where
minorities and underprivileged
populations are using marijuana and then
they're going to jail for it and their
lives are destroyed so there could be a
better way for example Brown University
I know they have a they have a prison
system where they're treating uh PE
people instead of penalizing them so
there could be many other alternatives
to that uh but but definitely we need
more uh we need more guidance in this
situation for sure so to be clear I'm
not talking about possession enhanced
penalty for possession for miners I'm
talking about enhanced penal for someone
who
provides to a to a
minor sure I mean yeah uh sure that
could maybe that that could work great
thank you question
doctor yeah um thanks um so I my
question is is we're talking about age
and we know that um children exposed to
marijuana sort of the earlier those that
are predisposed to things like
schizophrenia are you know that
increases the likelihood that they will
develop that mental illness do you have
any sort of age parameters sort of
capitalizing on what he was just saying
in terms of like exposure starting at
what what age it increases that risk and
by sort of what fold sure so the thing
is uh brand development actually uh
technically theoretically ends at age 25
so there's a beautiful uh factor out
there if you don't use substances till
the age of 25 or 26 it's very rare for
you to have any substance use dis
shoulder afterwards so for so so if a
person starts using substances at Agee
30 I'm not I'm not saying I'm not
encouraging that but if they do it's
very rare for them to actually have a
use disorder and and there are many
factors which go into this so when
you're younger and you use substances
right the thing is a lot of these so
it's easy when you're stressed out and
you know you're 19 or 20 you're stressed
out you you grab a joint and you smoke
it or vape it right the thing is that
you feel good you feel relaxed but the
underline causes problems are still
there right so the other caveat is that
you you don't develop cop skills so when
you when you stress out instead of
dealing with it and you know maybe using
strategies such as working out or
talking to your family or communicating
or whatnot uh you know these kids are
just picking up drugs and using them for
coping skills and then they don't learn
coping skills so it just becomes easier
for them to just have this as as as a as
a crutch and just keep using this in the
future so so so age 25 is when n
development uh is pretty much complete
in most people
H up yeah so um I I just want to clarify
it sounds like you you don't think that
raising the age to something like 25
which you know in theory if people were
using after that point would' put them
in a lot lower risk of a a a cannabis
use disorder would really change that
just based on the um sort of permissive
attitude shift or sort of cultural
change is that yeah so uh no the that's
a wonderful point you brought up so the
thing is that I think raing the age you
of course that's not the the as you said
that's not the solution but it may help
in the sense that at least people it's
different from 21 right so then people
might be thinking why is it 25 and it
would just make them think a little bit
more maybe like it would maybe make them
a little more cautious so maybe that
could be one good thing coming out of
it thank you anything
else
question um thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question question for
your testimony uh very
um comprehensive we appreciate that you
mentioned the ajama uh medical uh study
that where uh those the participants
developed uh cud cannabis use disorder
in 12 weeks uh can you tell me the age
range where those adolescents or adults
or a combination yeah so it was a um you
know I I think the age range was young
adult ads but there were yeah it was
mostly young adults if I'm not
mistaken yeah and that would be uh prior
to the age of
25 yes so we consider young adults till
age between 22 24 I would consider young
adults y okay that's great well while
the brain is still undergoing
development okay so that that makes them
um you know when the brain is is um
undergoing rapid development uh it's
more vulnerable to addiction correct
yeah y okay and um followup question
okay uh followup uh at the outset you
mentioned that you treated 100 have been
you are treating or have been treating I
have been treating like at this yeah
they're on my panel and you said 90% of
those uh are using uh cannabis uh like
the 90% is just my own estimate but most
of them are using more often than not
yep okay and so would the majority of
those be under the age of 25 as well yes
okay thank you thank you any other
questions for the doctor yes uh
representative
ol yeah thank you for your testimony
today doc appreciate it uh you're
talking about um addictive behavioral
disorders in
general and age 25 seems to be a
commonly heard number I know refered at
County when we've been talking about
setting up uh treatment centers for uh
various things and uh when we were
discussing the sexual orientation
there's something about your brain that
kind of gets set at age 65 for uh
pedophilia if you
will the question
is addictive disorders are present and
yet we allow children to smoke
cigarettes we allow children to well
young adults to buy alcohol at
21 so why don't we just raise everything
to uh
25 I agree in fact if it was up to me i'
I'd ban alcohol and and
nicotine great any other questions for
the doctor so doctor I'm gonna just ask
one more question again it's about what
would be in the bill proposed um what
would you add to a bill assuming again
legalization was going to happen what
would you add to the bill to to help
with the issue of substance disorder
substance use disorder or cannabis use
disorder what would you add to the
um I guess when when they're marketing
it or selling it at least provide this
information uh somehow uh you know um on
the box maybe that you know BR is
developing until the age of 25 and um of
course make sure the kids don't get it
and then if we can have some something
in there where if adults are using they
should make sure the kids it doesn't
fall into kids' hands and if it does
there should be some sort of a
consequence for that I'm not sure what
that is but something some
responsibility thank
you we're El set thank you Doctor very
much and I'm gonna turn the gabble over
to Senator s thank you so much we on
Amy she's
Cliffe we have do have a copy of written
testimony so you don't have to recite it
and didn't just uh clarify you know the
together just to order the commission is
is but to put together a recreational
policy any any suggestions you have for
that assuming it that it one would
become
law what what I'm what I'm you don't
have to read off the paper we're not
asking if someone supports recreational
campus or not but any advice on perhaps
okay thank you um I'll let you know who
I am and then I would like to actually
drill down a little bit in the mental
health harms and I don't know I know
that um Dr Shaw touched on a little bit
the mental health harms but that is my
area of expertise and and I think it's
really important um that you fully
understand the Cannabis induced
psychosis conversion to psychotic
disorder and how devastating that is for
families and and I think this is clearly
outlined in the um prescribing insert of
FDA approved um THC based medications
but doesn't get nearly enough attention
so if you're considering legalization
you're considering cannabis policy I
think what states have failed to do is
go back and look at that prescribing
information and really look at what does
that say all of the risks are clearly
outlined and the um amounts of THC that
are in the legal markets is astronomical
and what people are allowed to um to
possess and purchase are completely out
of line with what is in you know
outlined for risks in the prescribing
information
so thank you for allowing me to speak
today my name is Amy turncliff I have a
PhD in neurobiology um from the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
and did my post-doctoral training at
Harvard Medical School um my area of
expertise is mental health and substance
use disorders with a focus on cannabis
use and cannabis policy and the impact
on adolescent young adult Behavioral
Health and I've testified over the past
eight years in Massachusetts and I
cannot tell you how frustrated I and my
colleague clinicians and scientists are
and which is why we did put out a
statement of concern in in 2019
um because we really feel like a public
health framework for legalization has
not happened has not happened in
Massachusetts it has not happened in any
legal State um and then I think it's
important to say that my motivation for
being here is not strictly professional
it's personal I am a fourth generation
property holder in New Hampshire my kids
are the fifth generation to enjoy some
Su on beautiful Millan pond in
Washington and my family absolutely
loves the White Mountains we also own a
home in Waterville Valley um so as I
said I would like to you know I I would
reiterate what Dr sha said about the
brain isn't fully developed until the
age of 25 or 30 and there's a whole host
of negative consequences that result
from adolescent um and young adult
cannabis
use with that being said adult the the L
shows that and and in from the very
beginning showed that adults do and can
experience cannabis induced psychosis
and about um 35 I think the literature
has shown and I think it's in my I will
say it in my testimony about 35 to 50%
of people who use um will experience and
so to your point which is that while the
adolescents are if they experience
cannabis induced psychosis and they
don't stop using and they continue to
experience psychosis symptoms their
brain is still developing they have a
lot of neuroplasticity going on they're
probably more likely to convert to a
psychotic disorder literature shows
about 50% of those who experience
cannabis and psychosis go on to uh
convert to a psychotic disorder if they
don't stop using it's probably less
likely that adults will transition to a
um a psychotic disorder that isn't then
reversed when they stop using um but a
lot of people don't know that psychosis
symptoms is a consequence of cannabis
use or T I should say THC when I say
cannabis really it's THC and that would
include like Delta a I know parents
whose kids have been put into cannabis
and do psychosis from using um some of
the derivatives including Delta 8 THC as
opposed to Delta 9
so just one question is there any
recommendation or opinion you would have
on on what a warning label would say say
on a on a recreational product yeah so
in Massachusetts I was a lead author on
some bills that we um had filed on our
behalf to do just that so to warn about
um cannabis induced psychosis and and Su
suicidal thoughts and and um behaviors
and um anxiety um paranoia
hallucinations delusions you know that
go along with psychosis in addition to
um cannabinoid hyperemesis syndrome
which is not my area of expertise
however because canis policy is an area
of expertise for me I am in several
groups um for canab of you know where um
patients and families are discussing
canab H hyperemesis syndrome and I I
don't think again that most people
realize how devastating and
life-threatening CHS is um it is
extremely expensive with dozens and
dozens of visits to the Ed and
unnecessary surgeries and things like
that um so there's a I could say a lot
about what a warning label should
include but my concern is if the warning
label's too long yes I'm not sure people
are going to everyone's going to read it
yeah so you wanted to be obviously you
listed number of concerns I feel like we
listed all those concerns on a warning
label I'm not saying they're not it's
not worthy being on there but the
average consumer I want to
keep it let me tell you that in
California because I work closely with
folks in California who are also trying
to put more Public Health focused policy
in place they have proposed um a
required something that would be like a
prescribing insert but not just for
medical products a required insert that
goes with products that clearly outlines
the risks and where individuals can find
help or what they should do if they
symptoms so like a war a a larger
warning label inside the meag it's a
would be like an insert but what about
just the the label of the package which
is you know not not very large I most
it's half the size of my name tag I
think you're getting to the point which
are there are a lot of warnings there
are a lot of risks that people don't
know about so other ways to address that
are public awareness campaigns which I
don't particularly find all that
effective um because it's just hard to
get the message out but because there
are so many risks there you could do
something like tobacco where there's a
rotating warning and they have to change
the warning um every so often so that
all of the the warnings are seen by
consumers over a certain period of time
so you know it's not so cluttered but it
it's a real problem I mean it is but I'm
I'm asking you with your
expertise what would you prioritize or
on a warning label that's less than 50
words or less than 25 so I think you
have to prioritize that um if you're
pregnant or you know going to become
pregnant so pregnant women should not be
using um cannabis products even though
you know we know from the literature
that dispensary workers tend to
recommend them to pregnant women um I
would absolutely prioritize cannabis
into psychosis psychosis symptoms mental
health symptoms anxiety paranoia Etc if
you could perhaps maybe not at this
moment but maybe email the committee
commission a suggested warning label
that would be appreciated that can fit
on the package of a product it's going
to be very challenging like I said
you're up for it though
um so I I as I mentioned I I would like
to just dial down into the Cannabis
induc psychosis for a second um and it
is well accepted that THC can induce
acute psychotic symptoms that literature
comes from the clinical trials that
supported FDA approval of THC based
medications and um those were with
adults so um the association meets
Bradford Bradford Hill criteria for
causation which means that it's not just
those who were predisposed to develop a
psychotic disorder that will that
necessarily will uh develop the
psychotic disorder from cannabis induc
psychosis centuries of good quality data
um much from the last decade show that
THC can induce acute episodes of
psychosis in a dose dependent Manner and
that the conversion rate from Cannabis
induced psychosis to schizophrenia or
bipolar disorder is higher than for any
other drug induced psychosis at nearly
50% in human laboratory studies
concerning healthy adults being
administered THC it has been
approximated that 35 to 50% of those who
will experience psychosis symptoms um go
on to develop uh Canabis psychotic
disorder and I understand and I'm not
advocating that cannabis is healthy in
any capacity it's not the role of the
commission I just the commission is to
our role is to put together a
recommendation on on a recreational
policy on a control State Control model
which I I got I understand what you're
saying about that so I I guess we've
heard testimony I understand that
there's a harmful potential harmful side
effects of a lot of things I guess how
would you recommend we incorporate your
the facts in your testimony and what
you're saying and even with your written
testimony into a recreational policy
that
would mitigate those negative impacts I
I'm going to be completely honest with
you I don't think you can mitigate them
I think you need to prepare for how
you're going to and my last bit of
testimon about who's going to be held
accountable for the increase in
psychotic disorder who you know we have
Decades of experience and we talked a
little bit I heard about tobacco
industry so the tobacco industry
ultimately was held accountable for you
know through settlements and Etc and and
the outcome of that was a lot of change
in tobacco policy as a consequence of
those lawsuits those of us um who are uh
Public Health Advocates do believe that
there will be a reckoning down down the
road you heard Dr Shaw say you know
maybe a decade or more from now it's all
of this is going to come tumbling out
because there are a lot of parents whose
families are you know are really
irreversibly harmed by psychotic
disorder so you can put out public
awareness campaigns I mean we can list
off and I I did bring a copy of the
statement of concern and you may have
seen it already and there's a public
health framework that has been put
forward for uh legalizing um cannabis
and I would recommend if you want to
attempt to mitigate all of the harms
that will come with legalizing
commercializing I would strongly
recommend that you utilize a public
health
framework but I don't want to mislead
you and tell you that I think that is
going to mitigate the harms I I don't um
I do I think you might reduce them
slightly maybe um but and we have
reduced tobacco use over time but that
there's a kind of a curve that happens
with that right you see this huge huge
amounts of harm with thousands and
thousands of people dying hundreds of
thousands of people dying as a result
the thing with cannabis is you don't see
that Stark death right it's it's not
lung cancer per se or that we've seen so
far mental illness is is it creeps in
right and it it's it's hard to quantify
the United States doesn't do a great job
of
quantifying um mental illness and
researchers are starting to do that but
but I don't want like I said I don't
want to mislead you and tell you that by
using a public health framework which
like I said I think you should use that
you're it's going to be a Magic Bullet
because I'm certain it won't be and for
a lot of the reasons that Dr Shaw said
which is a lot of what happens is around
percept ction social uh social norms and
kind of Youth will gain access you can
put the age at 25 you could put the age
of 30 young people are going to gain
access and and in Massachusetts surveys
have been done and um and particularly
in western Mass where a lot of our
dispensaries are concentrated and
they're showing that the majority of
young people are saying they're getting
their cannabis products and they are
using more product than they had been
before legalization they're getting the
majority of their product from legal s
legal dispensaries and those prod that's
not to say they're walking into
businesses and purchasing because
they're not they're getting legal
product through diverted sources so what
we would might call like the gray market
so you know if you ask kids where are
they getting their um marijuana they'll
mostly say from friends or at a party so
it's social sources of access but now
they're accessing legal product through
social sources through an older sibling
through parents um they're paying some
you know like alcohol they're paying
someone to go get it for them so you can
work really hard and I'm not saying you
shouldn't work really hard to reduce
youth use but you're going to see an
increase in youth use for all of the
said would you believe that in two years
of a medical marijuana dis dispensary
opening in our region we had saw a 88%
surge in youth
use I would believe that would you also
believe that four toddlers were admitted
to our emergency room in THC induced
comr from from
Edibles the director of poison control
says sooner or later we're going to see
some deaths yeah so there was a um I
just
coordinated a a group of clinicians and
researchers in Massachusetts to meet
with our joint committee our legislative
joint committee on cannabis policy in
Massachusetts just last week actually
and they what the clinicians say is they
would like to see uh medical marijuana
go by the wayside because it it sends a
message to young people that it's safe
and healthy and so they believe and you
know for the reasons that Dr Shaw said
um there are FDA approved THC based
medications our medical marijuana
program doesn't have follow any of the
guidelines that are put forth in
prescribing inserts it doesn't have any
of the warnings and if you look as I
mentioned if you the daily recom the
maximum recommended daily dose is 28
milligrams so you can barely find a
product in Massachusetts that would have
that would deliver that daily dose it's
Way Beyond and I I provided a onepage
information sheet that kind of breaks
down the math um and lists the the
medications
as yeah very little if any so we don't
have um the same kinds of Grant programs
but I think California has a grant
program where a certain percentage has
to go back into prevention in
Massachusetts we don't have that um and
the the money goes back into the program
so I know that Massachusetts would has
been the Cannabis control Commissioners
have been tasked with putting out a
public awareness campaign I can tell you
they did not consult anyone in the
prevention or Public Health Community on
their campaign when they rolled it out
it it was I'm I'm going to be quite
blunt it was kind of the laughing stock
of um the prevention Community because
it it had a mom and and they put this on
billboards it had a mom and said
cannabis is legal in Massachusetts I
mean that was you know kind of the and
then it had a website go to this website
and it it really was was not based in
prevention science I I would encourage
you strongly and I know you do have some
prevention representation I would
encourage you strongly to utilize your
prevention professionals who know what
works in
prevention those of us who who do work
in prevention find it extremely
frustrating because we talk a lot about
wanting to reduce addiction but a lot of
our policies contribute to addiction so
you what percentage would
you as much as you could Poss possibly
manage
um do I think it's going to be enough to
offset the impact probably not um but I
would again encourage and and that is
one of the pieces of a public health
framework for policy is to prioritize
prevention um but at the same time we
know that our best prevention strategies
are what are called environmental
strategies and those really are our
policies and so when you take away our
our best really one of your best
prevention policies you have right now
is that you don't have legalized
recreational Cannabis when you take that
away you're going to take away one of
factors when you talk about uh the
mental health issues that legalizing
marijuana brings up uh was Massachusetts
prepared do do they have enough
counselors or or or treatment
professionals to handle the S the surge
they don't no and it I mean if you will
allow I would like to read this quote
from she runs um AOS first episode
psychosis program in at Boston Medical
Center and she has provided testimony
and I would like to read what she had to
say when she provided testimony to the
Massachusetts
legislature um she said and and again
she she's a clinical psychologist at
Boston Medical Center Boston University
and Harvard Medical School she said I
see many patients who have developed
psychosis after using High potency THC
products the average age that my
patients begin using THC is 15 and the
average age they develop psychosis is 21
earlier age of first use frequent use
and higher THC concent contrations are
all well-known risk factors for
developing psychosis while some of my
patients are lucky in that they are able
to stop using THC and eventually recover
from their psychotic episode most are
not so lucky for some The psychosis does
not go away even even though they stop
using marijuana and that is the changes
in brain function are irreversible for
others they are addicted to THC and
cannot abstain from using and thus
cannot recover from their psychoses such
histories are typical of a larger and
larger proportion of our schizophrenia
patients a growing body of research
demonstrates that these individuals are
not necessarily people who would have
developed schizophrenia without using
marijuana she goes on to say I love my
job but I hope you never need to bring
anyone in your family to my clinic
because they have developed
schizophrenia so absolutely not and and
I in this meeting last week I she
mentioned that she doesn't think people
even know that this is a symptom and so
that psychosis is a symptom so when they
experience psych psychosis symptoms they
tend to use more because they think it
helps their symptoms but in reality
they're
worsening I realized I'm just a stand in
this morning but thank you doctor for
being here and offering your testimony
um do you see any kind of association
between the mental health issues that
you're talking about right now and
mental health issues that seem to be
plaguing our country in
general so there hasn't been a
great kind of study so far of the
contribution of you know substance use
to the Adolescent mental health issues
certainly mental health issues occur in
adolescence for a variety of reasons and
substance use and cannabis use in
particular isn't the only you know cause
um though I will say and I and I I again
put that in here that there was a Wall
Street Journal headline that was legal
weed feeds the Teen Mental Health crisis
and I I will say that clinicians and
scientists do believe that it that is
true and so I think as I mentioned um we
do believe that there is a a worsening
and if you dial down and look at data
those that um have sub uh mental health
issues they do use substance is at
higher rates and it's hard to know right
people say well why are they
self-medicating what's coming first and
the the testimony I just read to you
from this um clinician she said her date
she is data to support the idea that in
many cases this the cannabis use is
coming first before the mental health
health issues in particular um the first
issues I I I think I it's I don't think
it's disputed that cannabis can be
harmful to to Children
particularly uh I guess any
recommendation on what a state like New
Hampshire should do when we're
surrounded now just say my district
district 22 I'm four towns I'm
surrounded by five dispensaries and I'm
fairly confident if Lawrence didn't have
such a high crime rate it would be if
the spency there so I I'm surrounded by
these stores so I'm I feel like where I
live all these harmful effects that
you're talking about it's already there
so so I guess my my question is what's
your recommendation to to New Hampshire
because we have the same I'm sure some
of the Border communities along the main
border can bring up the same issue and
I'm not sure about Vermont yet but I
feel like that's coming so so for us we
can do nothing yeah and keep it illegal
I get that and we we still have to deal
with the crossb issues so any
recommendation you have to St how to
deal with that so I want to touch on one
more piece of data that addresses what
you just said which is Western
Massachusetts as I mentioned is kind
kind of a hot spot for dispensaries and
so there are some communities that have
no cap on dispensaries and it's kind of
they call themselves kind of the wild
west of um of
commercialization and so they have um
they're they have kind of a county based
prevention system and so they they
survey kids across an entire County so
they have many communities in their in
their catchment and they have found that
the those communities that have and you
just mentioned five dispensaries that
have more that have dispensaries and
more dispensaries have more youth use
and more use related harm so again I'm
just going to say you actually in your
community if you don't have dispensaries
that is a protective factor for the kids
in your community well let me rephrase
this there's one in Tings Boro there's
one in drit and there's three in hav
okay okay that's and my community pelum
Salem ACC cled out mhm that just wraps
around us like a like a glove so I'm
asking what would you recommend someone
in that situation because it as far as
I'm concerned there's one of them if you
go in the parking lot you can see the
welcome New Hampshire sign yeah it's
true the one in hav so yeah what's your
recommendation on on an issue like
that I you know what I'm going to say
which is don't have any dispensaries in
your own Community you you might think
that that's not your kids in your
community in New Hampshire are seeing
what those those dispensaries they might
be accessing product from those
dispensaries if that's what you think I
would say do some data collection if you
are not sure what's what is the the
results of that but and yes if they're
seeing Billboards in Massachusetts we've
got a terrible problem with Billboards
the industry has been left to
self-regulate and so we have egregious
Billboards like cannabis for everyone
life is better with cannabis absolutely
no advertising to young people is a a
pillar of a public health framework um
but I would still say that the majority
of communities in Colorado opted out of
recreational Cannabis retail stores so
while there are in in Massachusetts we
have dozens and dozens and dozens of
communities including my own that don't
have retail stores so what I would say
is those
communities what the data has shown is
the communities that don't have retail
stores that is a protective factor for
their kids you're sending a message to
your young people we don't think we we
prioritize your health and safety and so
we're not going to have these stores in
our community and so the data has shown
that that is a protective factor for
you um thank you um the Surgeon General
in 2019 stated that no amount of
marijuana used an adolescence is known
to be
safe would that something like that on a
label um no am no amount of uh cannabis
use is safe for
adolescence be be something that you
would recommend
sure um I but I'm gonna say that young
people are not typically using packaged
product they're using product that has
maybe been sold
and then is you know you know purchased
by an adult and then either repackaged
or opened and here's you know you're
going to pay me this amount of money for
this you're going to pay me this for
this so
so maybe that that's helpful for parents
so that they're not providing product in
in you know to their kids um but with
that being said Massachusetts does have
labeling that says not not safe for for
anyone under 21 or not not for for use
Keep Out Of Reach of children things
like that uh the Surgeon General also
recommend recommended um THC caps at 5
to
10% um yeah and and yet we're seeing
sales at 99% yeah yes so I would again I
can I would happy to send the the public
health framework the list of policies a
THC cap and um products taking removing
or not having products that are
appealing to children so the candies the
cookies the gummies anything with sugar
California just tried to do that um
Colorado has tried to do that
Massachusetts trying to do that those of
us who are public health Advocates um
are really trying to do that and 10% THC
but I will say the naida defined dose
unit is 5 milligrams so I would caution
you on the percentage piece because
you've got you've got concent
flow um Edibles and so in Massachusetts
even some of our commissioners thinks we
have a cap we don't really have a cap um
on concentrate because the percentage
ranges so so broadly right you can have
50% or you can have 100% THC but you're
allowed to possess five grams so you
either have you know there you know we
do have to we have another witness
that's to testify and the original goal
of today's meeting is to start going
through the working draft so we can at
least kind of see what what we have on
paper and compare and compare the notes
on that as a commission so we do got to
keep I do assure that the Massachusetts
model is not something that I would
support and I and it is nothing close to
the policy that we're this commission is
looking into so Mr chair I do have one
one more question for our witness uh at
the outset you mentioned that uh the
Behavioral Health Community U drafted a
statement of concern is that could we
access that would you be able to send
that to our I I actually have a copy
it's not it's not a formal copy it's
just a printed copy but it's um a copy
nonetheless we can have if you want you
can hand it daily we can get some copies
made for the commission
okay is Scott
gagen thank you very much thank you
excellent
and I know you've heard this already but
again we're just asking for
recommendations yeah I get it on not
that I'm not asking whether you support
any type of recreational policy but if
one were to happen y any advice on how
to implement that in to totally
understand the question and actually um
I'm a good person to speak to this
question because I was in this position
in Maine so first let me introduce
myself I'm Scott gor um I'm a certified
prevention specialist I've been in the
prevention field for 18 years I've been
involved in cannabis policy and politics
in Maine for over 10 years um and in
fact I was actually part of the I led
the Coalition that opposed the
legalization initiative in Maine um in
2016 it was a coalition of Public Health
Behavioral Health healthc Care
Professionals um really broad Coalition
of folks that came out opposed that and
if you followed the election in Maine
you know it was very close um three
actually I know the exact number 3,997
votes between yes and no it was very
close um because of that I was afforded
an opportunity to join a sort of a
bipartisan if you will Coalition of
folks to come to the table to make
recommendations because it didn't early
pass it was going to go forward so you
had folks like me from the Public Health
Community you had folks from the
industry had folks from faith-based uh
Corners that were opposed to it um and
we did make some recommendations and I'm
happy to go through some of the
recommendations I would have I do want
to preface that though my experience in
Maine is a lot of that work
unfortunately was unraveled by A
legislature that does not take cannabis
seriously and so that would be my
warning is I can give you a whole list
of recommendations and I will I'll walk
I'll walk through things you should put
in your bill but if your legislature and
I don't know New Hampshire legislature
I'm just speaking of my experience in
Maine is there's not enough legislators
that take all the outcomes in the risks
that were just spoken about seriously a
good example of that is in Maine we have
two industries we have a medical
industry and adult use use industry the
adult use use industry requires testing
track and Trace all that good stuff our
medical industry does not so we call
marijuana medicine in main but we don't
require testing of it we don't require
track and Trace and it's because the
legislators don't have the courage to
come forward and do what they know needs
to be done everyone knows it's
ridiculous that something that's called
the medicine is not being tested for
just Metals just
contaminants because legislators won't
won't won't have the courage to stand up
that so again I'm going to walk through
what I would recommend you do but an
important piece of this would be you can
put forward the
best legislation that's ever happened in
this country when it comes to Canvas
legalization but if your legislature
doesn't take it seriously and either
doesn't pass it or Waters it down or
passes it and Waters it down in the next
session I'm just putting the I'm just
kind of raising the the warnings that
you can put the best thing forward but
the work after it is going to be just as
important to protect what you put in
there but again as as Dr turnl said I do
I do have to be honest I think if you
come up with the best thing that's ever
been done in the country I don't think
you're going to mitigate all the risks
and and the harms um so I would just say
that but what would I so things you
should shouldn't do that main is done um
to their credit the main office of
cannabis policy who is the regulator in
our state has in their mission statement
that they value public health and they
want to protect Public Health
Unfortunately they have not walked the
walk um we have a uh in Maine we had a
uh cannabis advisory commission which I
was a member of uh representing Public
Health um so the the office of cannabis
poliy wasn't really a great supporter of
that and uh through uh working with
legislators that's basically been kill
killed off so it doesn't exist anymore
so that's one Avenue that public health
the one Avenue Public Health has had to
have any kind of oversight on regulation
as main was was was done away with the
other thing that happened to me there
was a question earlier about uh funding
and funding going to prevention now
again to our credit and this was
something I advocated for personally was
a public health and safety fund so 12%
of uh tax revenues go into this public
health and safety fund the original
incarnation of that is it was to be
split between law enforcement and um
prevention so the the portion for law
enforcement was for training and the
portion for vention was for you know Ed
health education and etc etc um when I
when I advocated for that the intention
of that is the the the the public health
money would go to an entity in state
government that actually knew something
about public health but instead it's
with the office of cannabis policy which
know they're great they're fine people
but they do not have public health
expertise so the only thing that they
funded so far that remotely close to
prevention as a PSA Campaign which as we
shared is really low when it comes to
prevention really is not effective I I'm
not saying you you shouldn't do PSAs and
and campaigns they the science is pretty
clear they don't move the needle when it
comes to prevention preventing addiction
um young people young adults are across
the lifespan and so we've advocated over
and over and over again that for the
office of canus policy to work with main
CDC the actual Public Health experts to
work with them to get that money into
prevention coalitions and to get it on
the ground in the communities to do the
work and they won't do it they won't do
it uh um which is very very frustrating
so don't do that if you are going to put
money into public health and prevention
make sure it goes to where it can
actually be used in a useful way to the
to to part of state government or an
entity that actually has background and
understanding of Public Health uh
science um so I mean we've discussed
potency I mean I think you know Most
states have not done potency caps I
would highly encourage looking at uh
potency caps and as as was discussed the
trick with that though is is you know
10% again does seem to be sort of the
cut off and in a lot of States you're
really hard pressed to find Cannabis
products of that potency or or lower so
I mean addressing the potency is going
to be an important uh important piece
you know another other things that have
happened in Maine is originally in our
original legislation we did not allow
for delivery sales we did not allow for
vending sales we did not allow for
drive-through sales but that is slowly
starting to be watered down so we've
just we've just allowed delivery sales
but we we've also the kicker with that
is we've allowed we're also allowing
delivery sales to municipalities that
have opted out or have not opted in to
sales so most communities in Maine have
not opted in to allowing dispensaries
but because of this delivery bill that's
passed now deliveries can go anywhere in
main whether or not they've opted in and
so that's become kind of a way for the
industry due to an end round of of the
the wishes of towns in our state um so
that's been an issue um the the public
health warnings on on packages um
something that I've been really
frustrated with in Maine is uh you know
to our again to our credit we did there
is a requirement for health and safety
warnings uh but unfortunately when the
when they do the rules and regulations
for they said the minimum font for that
is six points so basically these health
and safety warnings are required on all
adult use packages or hiding in plain
sight no one ever sees them in fact when
I do presentations and and and what know
I do this little little gimmicky thing
where I hand out things in six point
fonts and to demonstrate how ridiculous
uh uh that is so I think that's
important but really again I I can't
stress enough I think if I can just
interrupt you do you know the font on
the side of a pack of cigarettes what's
that on the surgeon general's warning on
on a pack of cigarettes what's the font
size I honestly don't know off the top
of mayad I I feel like it's bigger than
6.5 the audience know anyone you have to
just it's got five six here's a package
I was going forgot get the no we we
don't have to hand the package I'm just
I'm asking he sent a font size I'm just
trying to hly don't I don't know for
forget the question I don't know to talk
it's probably a0 eight I would say I but
I just think it's ineffective right I
mean it's a good policy I mean it's good
that it's required I just think you know
the again when the the rules were
written it's they're written in such a
way that they can be hiding in in plain
sight but again I I can't stress enough
I think the important here is again I
can I can and I can email you a lot of
other recommend
but if again if you have a legislature
or if you have efforts to water that
down or to not take this seriously
because that is really the biggest to me
that's the biggest risk to our young
people when it comes to cannabis we
don't have enough adults taking it
seriously whether it's in the
legislature whether it's parents and and
uh other trusted adults whether it's
school officials what it's it's there's
this lacad isical attitude towards it
like it's not as bad as a bunch of other
things when it been perfectly laid out
why it is and even until our adults and
our legislators and what our Governors
take this seriously and and Dem and
convey that message not just through
what they say but through the policies
and to stand behind them and to make
sure that they endure um we're we're
just going to be we're just going to be
chasing our tals if you will so so I
would just again encourage you know at
the outset to have good Public Health
experts weigh in on this and have a seat
at the the table not just one but like
many you know do listening sessions go
around the state get get input from
everyone um in the Public Health
Community and and and not tokenism
because that's I've seen that too often
in states where if there is public
health input it's tokenism it's one
person at its seat that's again I go
back to the Cannabis advisory commission
I was the only person uh the only Public
Health seat and I had to fight to get
that seat and then they just did away
with the commission so again this needs
to be meaningful not to ISM input um
from public health but then go into it
with eyes open to know that the best
thing that you put out still probably
won't be enough it's I mean you should
still do it but
um and I can't stress enough funding
prevention and not just PSAs I think
funding your prevention coalitions
because they're going to have more work
to do when you legal if and when if or
when you legalize this they will have
more work to do in Sama the federal
government is not going to give them
more money because they can't they can't
fund coalitions to uh to do work with
legalized uh cannabis so they they're
going to have more work to do so they're
going to need more support uh from the
state whether or not they opt in because
even though they don't opt in there's
still people going to be buying and
getting access to it so I think
investing in your prevention Coalition
because they know what to do they have
the science they know what to do in
their communities to uh to protect
them
um so it's I mean I'll I'll take
questions and and um but again my my
colleagues before me really laid out all
the science I don't really need to go
into again because my frustration in
main again is just it's been the lack of
seriousness that this the issue has been
taken and it's it's it's impacting young
people I mean I've I could tell you all
kind of anecdotes of families that have
been impacted by this going to the
emergency room uh getting suspended or
expelled out of school um we just we
need we need adults to step up and uh
take it seriously now and in per perpet
is good morning thanks for your
testimony sure I I just a quick question
I I didn't quite understand you said the
money is there in Maine to to do the
prevention but they're afraid to use it
well I it's it's not be in my in my
opinion it's not being used properly
okay uh so and and I should uh so the
original uh the original version of the
public health and safety fund is 12% 6%
went to Law Enforcement Training 6% they
since have changed that language so now
it's no longer that 50/50 split so it's
a little looser so it doesn't half of it
doesn't have to go to to prevention so
that was one change that that that made
a little worse but then even the amount
money that is for the public health
prevention pieces it's with the office
of cannabis policy and they don't have
any public health experts on on staff
where it should have gone where I was
advocating for it to go to was to main
CDC it should have gone to main CDC
because they can get that money to the
prevention coalitions and M to do that
work instead the only thing that they've
done is funded uh some PSA campaigns
which really just science is pretty
straightforward that that has minimal if
any impact when it comes to preventing
addiction so I think if if just made
that change of if lawmakers or someone
would come forward the bill and says go
back to the 6% it has to go like I don't
know 85% of it goes to prevention
communities like at a minimum I think
that would be a significant change
that's something I've been advocating
for but so far uh it hasn't really gone
anywhere so I I hav even got an answer
to why they won't fund prevention they
me um thank you Scott for your testimony
um preven were and I I led you for
leading that Coalition you know that
that's really a near miss so you almost
got there so but that's a lot I didn't
get a lot of sleep in that couple of
years I'll say you yeah you push the
grer because of it but the the issue is
is we can't keep pushing up the boulder
up hill prevention with the policy
makers pushing back down on the Boulder
and that's exactly what this process is
designed to do even unintentionally
that's what's going to happen
preventions is designed to prevent the
problem from starting in the first place
and we do that by building protective
factors and mitigating risk factors this
is as I think Dr turncliff said one of
the the biggest um risk factors that we
could even be discussing in in a state
during a mental health and an addiction
crisis so I I can I speak to that just
for a minute so I I I just want to plug
that um samsa so that's the federal
funer of substance Services had did come
out about two years ago with an
evidence-based resource guide for
preventing youth marijuana use 18 and
under and one of the sections in there
they lay out the these specific risk and
protective factors for young people when
it comes to cannabis and what you just
said is in the sort of there's and
there's different layers to this so they
have individual risk factors uh family
risk factors School risk factors and
then like Community risk factors when
you look at the the list of community
risk factors it's basically actually I
have it on
my piece of paper here I can read off so
the the community level risk factors for
youth cannabis use are widespread
availability of cannabis greater
cannabis Outlet density more days and
hours of cannabis sales exposure to
cannabis marketing youth exposure to
cannabis marketing on social media and
products such as candy Edibles that are
attractive to use so just the very
existence and I I hate to to harp on
this but just the very existence of a
cannabis Market will be a risk factor
you thank you again um so again um we'
we've heard from our three speakers I'm
going to open up briefly for any public
comment based on the three speakers that
might want input because then our next
step is to start walking through the
bill and talking about sections in the
bill so is there anybody from the public
who would like to speak and come up come
on up to the microphone sir and just
make sure you state your name clearly so
we can get a document great you want to
around
St your name of the record and go ahead
thank you my name is Jim Riddle of
Hillsboro I'm a USDA licensed hemp
grower and I'm offering my comments
today on my own
behalf um earlier this year and and my
comments are directly related to the
charge of this
commission um earlier this year I
testified several times in support of HB
639 and when I did since I'm a farmer I
was asked how many farmers in New
Hampshire interested in becoming
cannabis
Growers and I didn't know that answer so
I worked with the new Hamp New Hampshire
cannabis Association the New Hampshire
Farm Bureau NOA New Hampshire and
several other Farm groups to conduct a
grower survey uh we had 69 people took
the survey 87% of The respondents Who
currently farm and the majority
currently Farm who took the survey
87% support legalization while
78% of those Farmers express interest in
becoming licensed Growers only 11% of
New Hampshire Farmers support the state
being the sole buyer and seller of
cannabis I understand that Paradigm has
shifted a little bit uh with the uh
franchise model now on the table
with the New Hampshire farmers who took
the survey uh support allowing licensed
Growers to sell cannabis
directly with 70% support 133% opposed
and 177%
undecided
89% yes so you looks like you're reading
directly from your testimony which has
been given to everybody we can all read
if you maybe summarize and come out with
points of what you want to talk about
well we can read if I could just this
the last statistic I want to present and
that's 89% of the respondant support
allowing New Hampshire residents to grow
6 to8 plants for personal use and I'd
like to shift gears now um during the
last commission meeting Senator abis
asked the question how can the draft
Bill be strengthened to minimize the
illicit
market and I over the weekend looked
through a number of scholarly articles
and the best one I found uh is from
Washington State titled suppressing
illicit cannabis markets after State uh
marijuana legalization so directly
relevant to the question that was asked
and if I could read uh a couple excerpts
from that study we found numerous
factors in the competition between
markets that that may allow illicit
supply of cannabis to survive many of
these factors can be directly influenced
by the regulation of the legal
system and uh things that impact that
are the level of taxes limits on
cultivation capacity and uh the burden
of the uh uh traceability uh
system
and to me after reading those studies it
really is clear that how the regulatory
system is structured really impacts the
uh elicit market and so in other
words the more barriers to being a legal
player the more you're favoring the ille
illegal Market I mean and so some of the
things I think that the commission needs
to be considering and I think this is
number one and that's in your charge is
to end prohibition because right now
people in New Hampshire are committing
Crimes by purchasing cannabis in
neighboring states there's already a
thriving illegal Market uh just because
prohibition but a allowing home
cultivation in every state that was
looked at in the study allowed home
cultivation that really undercuts the
demand for illegal uh products and
then the more people have access uh uh
the more it harms the illegal market and
you have to look at why do people buy
illegal cannabis it's because
it's lower price often it's
convenient that you can have somebody
come to your house it's a private
transaction you don't have to give your
license number um and there's just a lot
of tradition people have been doing it
in illegal States uh so they have
relationships but if you keep the
licensing fees low um you will
especially for smallscale producers uh
you're encourag them to participate in
the legal uh versus the illegal and the
same for the regulatory burdens keeping
it simple you want to apply and then
remain in the legal uh system so having
userfriendly
standardized product tracking that it's
easy to be legal and keep track of the
products and then a public education
campaign on those dangers that have been
talked about earlier by the uh
presenters um especially the dangers of
illegal cannabis because it's not
tested there are potential contaminants
there is the possibility of a rest um
whereas legal cannabis uh needs to be
tested not just for potency and Turpin
and the qualities but also potential
contaminants and that's contaminants
like mold that was talked about but also
contaminants with illegal drugs like
fentanyl um but I also listened to the
comments at the last meeting from the
Assistant Attorney General Madison and
Mr Madison made it clear uh that a
state-owned label which is really what
you're talking about and then
franchising the use of that label to
retail stores would not isolate the
state from liability or possible civil
suits but he also pointed out that
Congress through Appropriations writers
has established a carel for medical
cannabis and given that reality
as well as the fact that New Hampshire
does have a well-established medical
program I've come up with a novel idea
and I haven't presented this to anyone
except my wife um and that is to build
out New Hampshire's legal regulatory
framework on the medical program that
already exists increase the number of
licensed dispensaries and add criteria
such as insomnia anxiety appetite
self-care in order to qualify for a card
and the cards could be sold through the
state liquor stores so you're not taking
the risk of selling cannabis or branding
you are selling cards you are and the
dispensaries could also sell these cards
and then under this model both residents
and out of-state Shoppers could purchase
a card for a reasonable
price they essentially and then they
could purchase tax free cannabis in New
Hampshire but essentially you're
capturing that Revenue through the
purchase of these cards You' have you'd
have accountability on who the customers
are you could do traceability of Health
impacts you also can trace the products
and when a person would purchase the
card they would agree to follow all the
legal requirements they would agree not
to provide cannabis to persons who are
underage whatever age you decide side
that is they would agree not to drive
while impaired they would receive those
warnings not just on the pack that was
passed around but in that actual process
they would be warned about possible
negative uh Health impacts including for
pregnant nursing women and they would
attest to hold the state harmless uh so
I think it I know it's a novel idea uh
but I would like you to consider it
um because I think it can protect the
state from civil suits it will generate
Revenue without imposing either an
excise or a sales tax and it builds on a
successful program that already exists
so thank for your you for your time and
attention thank you Mr riddle questions
for Mr riddle
Frank thanks just one quick question um
would you be willing to share the
methodology for the survey and the
questions you used yes there is a uh uh
and I'm not
representing New Hampshire cannabis
Association I put the survey together
there is a very detailed blog post on
their website uh NHC can.org uh that
shows graphs and uh the methodology is
basically I came up with a list of
questions that had been you know uh
submitted to me when I testified things
that it appeared that legislators wanted
to know and we worked with uh New
Hampshire Farm Bureau to refine those
questions uh then once we had it ready
to launch we asked Farm Bureau NOA New
Hampshire which is the Northeast organic
farming Association of New Hampshire uh
the New Hampshire herbal Network fruit
and vegetable Grower Association a few
other Farm groups to help distribute it
it was open during about second half of
August all of September we closed it
September 30th people voluntar L logged
in to the website it took about 10
minutes they were able to both answer
the questions as well as enter comments
and we uh will be Shar you know the
Cannabis Association will be sharing
those comments but uh that's basically
the methodology so it wasn't that we
were calling people up what's your
opinion on these answers uh it took
voluntary initiative on the respondents
part cool just one followup follow so in
terms of like how representative that
because it's seems like 69 is a
relatively small number I assume look
quickly there's like 40 at least 4,100
commercial farms in New Hampshire right
and and Farm Bureau has a membership of
about 2,000 so yes it's a small
percentage so how representative that is
but we we definitely had people
motivated uh who were uh opposed you
know weigh in it wasn't just targeting
or anything it was but it was voluntary
okay cool thank you and it was there
were several rounds of notices that went
out inviting people to take the survey
further questions for Mr riddle seeing
none thank you Mr R thank
you all right so here's what I'm going
to propose I'm going to take a we'll
take a five minute break so we're going
to go take a bio Break um and we'll come
back we're going to Jump Right In does
everybody have a copy of the proposed
draft language for the bill um if not
I'll get that out while we're on break I
think is that yeah I think there's
copies in there so I'll get them out to
everybody and then we're just going to
start on page one and start walking
through the bill so five minute break be
11:35
back all right everyone ready to rock
and roll all right does everyone have a
draft of I gave it out all right it's
when I say it's a draft it's again
nothing in here is
set but my goal is to kind of go through
this B section I'm not saying we do the
whole thing today uh if there's anything
that's in here that is
just I don't know we disagree on
whatever but we want to make sure this
actually can work in the real world um
you know I'm not going to necessarily
accept testimony from the public right
now but you know a thumbs up or a thumbs
down you know we'll exercise my
discretion if we're going to allow
comment on a particular section limited
to that
all right does anyone have the
draft all right do you want to tell the
the it just says draft on it so oh I
didn't know if you took it from
something it's not it's not a a previous
bill that has ever been
filed so it's kind of a combination of
several bills that have been filed so
the reference one bill number would
probably be confusing um but this is
what we got so far for Mr chair I did
put out the extra copies we had every
member got distributed one and we put
some extras out for the public to be
able to read so they could follow along
with our current
draft right so Mr sh just a question so
we got some suggested language from new
Futures I didn't know if that was
incorporated into this draft I'm I don't
believe so but that's I didn't want to
keep handing out drafts and making
changes to the draft because there's no
reference number of this so it's not
that I don't value what the new futures
um input would be but I just didn't want
to make any more changes since I already
started circulating that but when we get
to the sections that would apply um
obviously you please please bring that
up okay so page
one uh I think it's just it's purpose in
finding personally I think you can just
strike the higher first paragraph I
don't think it's necessary to make that
you want to leave
it so Mr chair if we're going to leave
it I I do want to strike at least a
couple words out of it I think the
taxation I'm okay with the whole idea
that we strike it because again um not
it doesn't have any force or eff of law
it's just more of a policy statement
than anything else so it's not
necessarily means anything but if we are
going to do it uh leave it I want to
strike the word law uh after allowing
where it says law enforcement to focus
on violent and property crimes and just
strike that and move on to the rest
about generation Revenue generation my
purpose in in in making if if we move
forward with the legalization model it's
not because I want law enforcement to
focus it it's because we either think
it's legal and we should do it um or not
but it's not about law enforcement
focusing on violent crimes and property
crimes um there you should be focusing
on crimes period um so I just want to
strike that law enforcement to to focus
on violent and property crimes because
that shouldn't be
something our state is looking to do is
have them focus on that we should have
them focus on just enforcing the law
perod that paragraph is and and whether
you agree with what it says or not has
no impact on the policy so it just makes
a long Bill longer and I'm just trying
to cut this down I if that doesn't mean
that it doesn't there's not good points
in there I
just
representative uh thank you Mr chair uh
the reason I suggested leaving it in is
uh from the comments that were made by
by the attorney general and that the
state needs to document
why it's doing what it's doing in light
of a federal prohibition that exists so
you're creating a
guidance I think uh where this while it
has no effect on the policy within the
state it does have a defense when you
get into a challenge to the law either
at the state or federal
level
for my testimony I don't uh know that
the
findings um would have relevance for any
federal enforcement action um it's
really the the underlying regime or
compliance with that regime that may to
your comment about civil
liability
um for example using that New York case
it's a preemption Challenge and so the
uh the state finding wouldn't influence
enforceability under um a federal claim
so um I I wouldn't want my testimony
from from last week to indicate that the
documentation of a purpose um is
necessarily a uh mitigates risk or or
legal risk Mr
chair um understanding what you're
saying there however when uh other uh
legislation we had
has relied upon findings in order to
justify its existence particularly when
it comes to a federal level and when you
put down and saying that we're firmly
placing the state of New Hampshire in
this case in Contra or contraposition to
the position of the federal government
you're immediately moving this to where
eventually it's going to have to be
resolved because you're creating a uh
jurisdictional uh Point CounterPoint in
the first paragraph uh of the
legislation which would then allow
somebody to go down to Washington and
have some fun standing up and going oh
you glorious people up there so let me
just focus so on that there's 13 of us
here does if you support leaving that
par that's uh that section in there
that's page one that's paragraph one you
want to leave it in there we can make
some changes just if you support leaving
it in just raise your
hand striking it just
gone and then that again I don't think
that
that I think and then going to section
two um I think when it comes
to section e it says canvas so the stage
will be tested labeled and subject to
additional regulations to ensure that
the consumers are informed and pro
protected and protect the environment at
section uh
2E um there's been some suggestion that
maybe the testing is done by the state I
I don't know if the state would have to
do that themselves it should be a
private company the state can contract
with I think I don't there's any comment
on that or
any any direction we should go
Mr again I don't I don't think that that
that section e States whether it's state
tested or state an independent lab
tested um I think by just leaving the
statement in there I think it's clear
that testing is required and then how we
do the testing can be can be worked out
I'm assuming there's some testing
language later on that talks about that
we can talk about whether it's an
independent lab or a state run lab I
think it would kind of be against it
would be I hate to use this terminology
but the fox you know uh guarding the hen
house we' let the state test its own
product and allow it for legalization
for sale within its own facilities um I
think we'd scream about that in a
private industry and I think we should
probably scream about that in a in a
state run industry as well that an
independent outside lab testing is
appropriate so I would leave that as it
is Mr chairman um the we believe that in
point of fact uh we do test our own
products uh in this state for example uh
blood uh samples for DWI is tested by a
state lab we the Chiefs believe that U
this should remain in state the testing
facility should be a state one facility
I think it definitely remain in the
state it's just whether it's run no and
what we believe it should be a state a
yes we can I think with what Senator
Lang said that we you know leaving it as
it is we can address that when it comes
to the actual policy in the bill um for
paragraph 2f it says some tax revenue I
I would just put some of the tax just
strike that out so revenue generated
from legal cannabis will be sport
programs for and go from there Mr chair
I just wanted to also add a potential G
that was recommended which I think is a
good one adding as G the marketing and
advertising of cannabis to miners shall
be prohibited I think you know based on
our conversation today that's a
minimum and you want to add that to g to
g uh one two
G one two
G all right does anyone have a problem
with that nope I I think that's that's
very reasonable
recommend it I um you have this
a I
want I'd rather write that write down
that
section you have
right
and the just for the committee's
commission's doc uh reference this is
at FS have
this the
memo does anybody oppose to adding
letter g in that that line about no no
we're good no one no one on the
commission supports advertising canas to
M good a press in the
room right new the then if you go to
line 34 page one it's the new sub
uh think it gets into the substance
abuse in Recovery Fund management
distribution of the
funds anyone have any comment on that
section Mr
chairman is that section paragraph F you
talking
F yes to section F uh could you
shall I'm sorry Chief where are you at
um par
revenue it's shall be used Asos as
to it's basically the whole the entire
page to is it's the substance abuse a
prevention and Recovery Fund and
management distribution funds does
anyone have any comment on that yeah so
again referencing that new Futures memo
there there was a suggestion to add
treatment so we would be adding
treatment to
online five in the title so it would be
Substance Abuse Prevention treatment and
Recovery funds adding it in line seven
substance Abuse Prevention treatment and
Recovery funds and then again on line 12
sh administr to Substance Abuse
Prevention treatment and recovery 5 S
M you want to add substance
treatment uh I think there might be one
that for all the the the treatment
programs here are these any any of these
going to be private treatment programs
or are they all is it all just going to
it none of this says whether it's state
run or federal run it's just that the
funding can be used for it so I assume
it could be both um state run or private
centers and how would and how would a
private Treatment Center get get access
to the
funding well that's how they do it now
right so they apply an individual would
apply to DHHS for for a substance under
a substance abuse and um and go to a
treatment center whether it's alcohol
opioids or anything else and they would
be granted funding um and DH just has
approved
programs how would we establish by rule
on page
chairman would just the wording here
that U fund shall be deposited into the
that fund and the St divide commissioner
Department of Health and Human Services
in coordination with the governor
Commission on Alcohol and Other
Drugs are we saying are we saying the
funding from whatever tax or Revenue
this bill would go would go into the
governor's commission with the alcohol
fund funds and then be like it is now
and then be administered by the by HHS
now right now the alcohol fund the money
actually goes to the commission and then
that then then whatever allocations they
make to the HHS
then uh does the actual uh
funding the way I read this it would go
into the
same it's not clear here whether that's
what but the way the way it's written on
and on the second page it looks like it
goes to the same fund and is there any
issue on commingling the f I guess
that's
number
Mr chair I would say from an accounting
standpoint the money the the revenues
need to flow through the commission to
the fund for auditing uh from an
auditing standpoint so because the
commission will be in charge of the
sales just like we do with the alcohol
fund so much of that money from the
revenues of the commission flows into
the fund so if we're saying the
revenue minus
whatever uh working capital the
commission needs the the proceeds would
fund Mr
chairman we're just a little bit
concerned with the potential of
co-mingling of
funds and we were wondering if we
couldn't add something to the effect of
of a can cannabis Substance Abuse
Prevention and Recovery Fund an
independent fund that would keep
whatever uh funds come from sales Etc
separate distinct what yeah so I I
actually was looking at the the um the
new Futures and it it looks like they um
when they're suggesting some changes
they actually didn't highlight an area
and so I was looking back at that and
that was there saying insert at the
beginning of the bill that in addition
to treatment um to creation of a
separate non-aps fund for prevention
treatment and Recovery that does seem
like a reasonable idea but so at the at
the top here in the
[Music]
last so you know what we're looking at
there it is I told I had it I just there
you go I'm trying to multitask take
notes I need I need four hands to do
what I'm doing so I was trying to cheat
off yours sorry doing a good job oh no
she kept tell she she's tough she gab me
down all right so we we we need
to make a had this be a separate fund a
dedicated a dedicated fund yeah do laure
a dedicated dog la a dedicated fund with
a similar objective but it has to be
separate it also needs to pass through
liquor for auditing purposes is that the
consensus y i I just want to make sure
the the governor's Commission on Alcohol
and Other Drugs they have a they come
out with a three-year plan and they they
have legis as you know legislative
appointed uh members on there uh and
people from the subject matter experts
and they come up with a plan on what's
best how to how to um use funding that
they get for the alcohol fund and and I
believe that I believe that the money
should be put into that fund to be
consistent why I have two funds I just
want to make sure why have two different
funds to do the same thing well
fundamentally I agree with you but I
think there was concerned about mixing
the alcohol that's revenue from alcohol
sales with
revenue from Cannabis
sales I think one of the one of the
reasons you should have something
separate is the alcohol money goes to a
few different
places this money would be specifically
for Canabis period it would be
specifically for the kist non- elapsing
dedicated fund the alcohol fund now is
used for a variety of purposes we use it
in in for the Medicaid expansion which
is a key key issue which I I think think
at the beginning of the alcohol fund was
never never a purpose so that's been
designed it's a new purpose it's been
created and it's quite specific chief
that that that it's that it's going
there U and I and I think the
flexibility of the alcohol fund is
something that has been uh the
legislature has used on a number of
occasions that's that's all I'm I'm just
putting out that there is flexibility
there has been flexibility there where
this would be much more specific
if this would be a dedicated flood to
wood for wood purpose
so chair if you look at the new Futures
here I'm not gonna lie I haven't read
this old paragraph in a while if you
just cut that and put that in here but
this uh uh so this is this paragraph is
already in and we're just adding the
green but then this is what they're
talking
about so Mr chair if I can for one
minute so again I I tend to agree with
uh David over there in that um I'm not
just remember we have a cannabis fund
which is the first segmentation of money
right that that comes from the retail
stores and goes into the Cannabis fund
it's from that cannabis fund that we
then disperse the other rest of the
funds from so in in the case of
dispersement when we get down there we
send 50% to education in this in this
model which means we're now mixing
cannabis funds with education so why are
we concerned about mixing cannabis funds
with treatment programs um because every
person I heard testify talk about
treatment didn't talk about treatment
with cannabis alone they talked about
treatment in conjunction with opioids
and treatment in conjunction with
alcohol treatment uh in conjunction with
other uh you know prescription drug
medication right so again I think
treatment and and rehabil not
rehabilitation but um those other
services are treatment right and so
segmenting it out I don't know that
anybody's going to walk through the door
and say I just have a marijuana problem
and that's the only thing they have and
and that's what this money would only be
used for so I think it it we we better
serve the citizens of the Hampshire by
putting it into the treatment fund and
allowing for the broad base of treatment
and services which would include alcohol
and other opioid
addictions she wants it looks like she
wants to say something
uh Mr chairman I'm fine with the money
going into the fund I just want to make
sure that the accounting of the money
is
separated in the liquor ledgers as
separate funds and if the money goes
into a dedicated fund that's fine we
again like everything else The Liquor
Commission does we we're we're neutral
on how you use the money we just want to
make sure the accounting process of
where the money comes from and an
auditing trail of where the money comes
from Mr separate representative from new
Futures I know we been referencing the
Handover that you provide to us if you
can just perhaps well and I as a
followup to this conversation I I wanted
to know if this was added because of the
concern that the alcohol fund is always
raided
okay Kate fry vice president of advocacy
from new Futures I'm sorry didn't
explain this section well enough in um
The Narrative for this what I was
pointing out is that treatment should be
in that title because it's the full
Continuum prevention treatment and
recovery but what I neglected to say is
in our principles what we have said is
that the funding from um uh cannabis
sales just like we have in the past with
alcohol should go to reduce the harm
of an addictive product that for um is
um on this on being sold in New
Hampshire so what we've learned from the
alcohol fund 20 years in the making um
it was fully funded at 5% this year 20
years after it was put into place it
never had before it never had been
funded before because the way it was
constructed it was often swept out
during the budget process and used for
other means and so what we did this year
or in previous drafts of cannabis
languages we learned from the alcohol
fund and what we learned from actually
the opiate abatement dollars that were
coming into the state was to complete um
to set up a completely separate Fund in
the treasury that cannot be touched and
can't be incorporated into the general
fund we merely just cut and Pace that
opiate abatement fund language and we
created this fund and I agree with with
the commissioner because of accounting
with the liquor revenues we feel that
those funds should be separated but on
the concern um why we have the
connection with the governor's
Commission in their very important role
of strategizing for the state we do feel
like they should have an understanding
of how much is coming into the state for
through canabas through alcohol and the
larger strategic plan and help advise
where the funding should go in both of
those pots because they're in charge of
the larger issue of substance misuse and
have a say on that instead of creating a
separate advisory commission so two
different funds but a commission that is
working with the Department on the
oversight one commission basically
overseeing two different funds yes but
with the larger issue of prevention
Recovery
I if it can be done done with the two
with that fund
going if the language could say that the
uh alcohol uh Commission on Alcohol and
Other the drugs would have the same I
don't want to say power the
same ability to be able to allocate
those funds and then I just want to make
sure that it's that group is deciding
where that money is going I think we can
we can reserve making a recommendation
on this and perhaps we'll kind to
consult with someone in DHHS on this
particularly and maybe we can talk to
someone that's on the uh Governor's
Commission on alcohol it certainly was
my intent with this language with the
governor's Commission on alcohol because
they are the oversight of the alcohol
fund so that was my intent but if we can
tighten that up I'm happy to help with
this we're on the same page yeah so Mr J
again under section three it's pretty
clear again I guess this just creates
two separate funds keeps them separate
but still allows uh the DHHS to work
with the governor's commission um to
deal with dispersement yeah and so under
section three so I think we're actually
okay even though we kind of talked
ourselves into a circle um but I think
we're actually okay we can add the
treatment language again that is the
specific under 12j chapter 12j it's the
governor's Commission on alcohol and
drug abuse prevention treatment and
Recovery yeah right so that's what it's
consistent with that with their charge
and so I think we're actually okay if we
just add the word treatment in there
section three still allows the um the
governor's commission to work with DHHS
on dispersement of funds for appropriate
programs so it's it's fine fine is
adding the treatment is
that that really is all that has to be
done because that's from a previous um
what you have I believe in this is from
the previous draft Yeah so it's on five
online five 7 12 and
not to keep on talking about I just want
to make sure that the language is is
clear enough that these funds would work
the same way as the alcohol fund where
it is the commission who decides where
the money is going to go and then the
HHS then administr here it's not clear
it's just ask it it seems to give the
ability and power to HHS with input from
I believe I copied the language for the
Governor's commission with the
relationship with the alcohol fund we
can go back and double check but I think
I copied that language already in there
we can double check that and in in
respect to section three on L
21 if there's any maybe a suggested
language we can present that the next
meeting Dave maybe if you if you could
look at that and see how you want to
rewrite that section which talks about
um uh
making distributions from the fund so
why don't you look at that and see if
you can come back at the next meeting
with language that would be suffice for
the Governor's Council okay for the
you all right so on to page onto page
three I think the begin top of that page
is just discussing the report that would
be provided every every two years which
is similar that's done a lot of
different so we don't think we need to
really cover that um M actually you have
a question Mr chair so
right now it's the duty and
responsibility
of the alcohol commission to provide the
F report about the uh programs um and
the and the efficacy of those programs
so was our goal here is to move this
over to DHHS now or is to leave the that
reporting mechanism in with um the fund
with the Commissioners so it says a
report on cost effective and outcomes
programs required under Section again
I'm looking at 12 J5 commencing January
1st 2020 and annually thereafter the
commission has to issue a report so my
question is do we need to create another
report because they're already talking
about each report will contain
evaluation of four programs treatment
programs prevention programs programs
selected to be chosen from among the 10
highest dollar programs so they already
have a full reporting requirement for
distribution of funds and the programs
they support is Our intention to create
a other report that they have to create
I I think as long as money is going to
be allocated to this fund and
distributed with with the discretion of
by
DHHS them providing a a separate report
on this fund These funds particularly is
important now could that be merged into
the report with alcohol can be but I
think it's different Revenue sources so
I
don't I'm not sure we want to eliminate
it have a separate report any have any
opinion on that the TP typically what
what happens within I I can be corrected
if anybody else but typically what
happens with the commission with alcohol
and Other Drugs is that allocations on
the number five during the Contracting
process HHS will will ensure that all
these things happen when they
contract okay so we want to leave it
with DHHS for the
reporting I I believe so yes okay that's
fine I don't want to put words in Amo
but they typically do this during the
Contracting process anyone else any have
any objection to leaving the report
DHHS on page three it talks about uh
lines six to nine this is actually a
problem this is a problem in existing
legislation where you know a valid
passport you know the Bold is would be
added but it's by by a country with whom
the United States maintains diplomatic
relations it was always believed that
was a drafting era that United States
passport wasn't the an appropriate form
of identification for alcohol they've
been attempting to fix it in every
cannabis bill not a standalone here it
is again but it would be no explanation
why you can accept a passport from
Ireland or England but not a United
States passport in America but that's
how the law is written so but does
anyone have any problem with the United
States passport being as fish form of
identification purchase liquor and
matter lines 11 through 17
um I will say before we get into the
policy of the uh the forfeiture
fund this has been a hot that has been a
separate Hot Topic issue in the
legislator and perhaps i' striking that
out for the time being and not dealing
with the drug forfeiture is issue you
will that can sync sync the ship if you
know what I
mean does anyone have any objection with
that your your your recommendation is to
strike section five starting on line 11
yes support that and I'm not commenting
on the policy either way I'm just
explaining that that
policy is is worthy of its own B
separate aside from this I don't anyone
has any disagreement with that or so
eliminate
forfeiture well not eliminating it's
the we
good
on lines uh 19 through 20 uh 23 any
added I think they might have left out
the word harvesting or cultivating
it it's
just cultivation enough or we need to
harvesting we're fairly confident the
same thing but you never know when it
just add the word cultivation after
cultivation and harvesting we
two
okay now we're in the uh definition
section it starts
31 question sure if this should become
law even
need
question I'm sorry what was the question
again Chief well uh if if the
legalization becomes law do we actually
need alternative uh treatment centers
any
longer yeah so
again I don't necessarily think we need
the definition because we're only
referencing another definition in you
know in in law anyway so I'm not sure
that it serves any purpose so it it may
if someone's looking for the definition
within the statute they can go to the
definition section oh and find where
it's def what what is the definition so
I don't think it hurts having it in
there although I do think that it we're
still going to have medical dispensaries
and alternative treatment centers so I
think we leave we leave it in for that
reason that's exactly correct because if
you have a reference to it in the law
you have to Define it in the law yes
he's
corre he's two in he's two in a row he's
all right so we can leave the the
35 I wanted to make sure that we're not
this is not regulating CBD extract and
that's its
[Music]
own that's it own own right now you can
buy that in a lot
of you can buy that in aot different
stores right now without a
license you know we don't want to
require a license for just someone
buying CBD
oil do do we want to put that
phraseology in there does not
include blob
blob I I agree with representative ol
you know we have we have to make sure we
protect those stores that are selling
selling the stuff at like spas and stuff
like that and uh you know there's creams
being being sold that are they're
important to people
so is this definition accomplished that
as it's
but seems like it might be helpful to be
more specific
just say that this excludes CBD only
product
yeah that could be included in the last
sentence you know or other product such
as CBD oils or CBD products derivatives
derivatives derivatives so I will Mr
chair I think you and I had a brief
conversation about this or I sent you
some emails on it anyway CBD is going to
be an interesting conversation point
right now um because it's being pushed
in a lot of places and now we have
conflicting law happening um the city of
Rochester shut down a CBD coffee shop
because technically according to the FDA
CBD Is Not An approved approved product
for the inclusion in into a food product
and so that's creating some
some spot enforcement for lack of
metaphrase um that's going on and never
mind I I I just came back from uh Las
Vegas and I attended the National Beer
wholesalers Association CBD drinks
whether alcoholic or non-alcoholic are
starting to become all AR R and Estates
that are not regulating and dealing with
this issue of CBD and THC infused other
products that may be food or otherwise
so again I I I I just caution that by
not taking a stance we're
leaving conflict out there um that's
pending so they shut down the coffee
shop serving the food that won't make
you impaired but if you buy it in a
candy bar that will make you impaired
it's fine I'm just making a statement
that that again we have this conflict of
of CBD and a hemp deriv product that
that people conflate with THC and low
low potency THC products and what does
that mean we definitely have to protect
the spas that are selling creams and
stuff like that I mean that's CBD yes
but they're not they're not ingesting
that so I'm sorry that's like not a food
and is there we have a doctor on the are
you aware of any different effects of
CBD benef health benefits if it's
ingested as opposed to using whatever
you just
does it matter does that really M I'm
just do we really seems that we're over
regulating that if there's no yeah I
mean I I think that the only thing that
I would say is if we're adjusting it
like it was brought up by by some of the
presenters today is that there a lot of
the products says it's un regulated do
have THC in them and that gets a little
bit tricky like if you test what's out
there like at the co-op um you know like
10 to 20% of those products do have THC
or would show up positive on a drug test
which which makes that a little
complicated I think when you're
ingesting it um but yes I mean so just
the product I mean different vectors are
absorbed differently so a topical would
be absorbed differently than a than an
oral tincture or something like that so
I think it is different uh doesn't
matter I I don't I don't know but but it
differently I suppose what we can tackle
that inconsistency at a different time
seems to me that
but we want to keep those products that
are being sold
now continue to be sold as they are um
is there I know our friends from one of
our friends from Maine is here he's at
my 12 o'clock is have you seen the
definition that we're
referencing have you have you do you
referencing
does someone have a copy we can just I'm
just wondering if you can offer any
comment on that particular definition if
there's any problems
with M Mr
CH the
the paragraph two Roman two it talks
about topical or oral
administrations now it does not talk
about food products food products is a
different
category and the store in Rochester was
manufact facturing or selling a food
product that
was
contaminated by CBD
oil so it was a contaminated food
product that's a different section Al
together uh regarding law
again that's outside the area what we
have currently being sold are
CBD
um products direct
products those products are
not uh what's the word
for well they are topical and they are
oral but they're not food products so
they're
not they ain't
food so if we want to put food in there
someplace that just gets rid of that
issue
entirely H how there's a federal
Mr chairman how would that account for
like what we're talking about with the
coffee like I know the coffee shop in my
town puts the CBD if you order that in
the coffee but it's that's it's because
they're separate items you want getting
shut down be careful I I say say where I
live
set um but right so like if they're
separate products but it's being
introduced into another product as
opposed to like a like ready for
so I again there's a federal definition
of cannabis if anybody wants to hear
that but I don't know where we want to
look at other states definitions and
come back to this discussion so C CBD
oil product everything is legal you can
buy it right now at all variety of
different types of stores all right or
businesses we don't want to change that
no one's getting impaired from CBD if
it's just CBD so I want to make sure
that this definition does not disrupt
the what's existing now well but I if I
may what I heard from the doctor is that
um things that are things that say they
have CBD in it are testing with levels
of THC as well is that what you said
yeah that's correct that's what the data
shows and that's what they presented
today is that there are even if it's
labeled as something that you can buy at
the co-op as CBD only product a
THC Now by testing positive do you mean
the traces of it or is it something that
would you would actually make if it's %
or less it's not considered
Canabis okay so so that's that's why um
the law the law here our consensus is we
at some of that to be integrated into
okay and the other thing is seeds and
the defition of cannabis the DEA said
not so but then wouldn't if if that's
the case wouldn't seeds then be
are
so uh so what we what I would safe when
it comes to perhaps
enforcement if you're going to be
tracking the seeds I don't see the sale
uh would that defin we need to keep that
language where seeds in there i' rather
keep it in and take it out later than
take it out now and wish we kept it in
my my but I'm not
sure I'm not sure I'm correct in doing
that I think that that would be the
safest way to do it in the majority of
the the finite definition of what we're
rule so in respect to this paragraph
that we been is there any changes though
that we think should be made to
it I know there's suggestion of striking
the word seeds but is there does anyone
have any comment on whether we should do
I I it feels like this is a larger I
mean we could spend the however long it
feels like we need to come back to this
I don't know if what what the chair's
intention is of you know um if you want
to revisit let's say we agree to keep it
in and then next meeting you say oh
here's the information let's take it out
this is not set in stone it just if we
come to a consensus on something you
know in I think the public can here are
reasoning there's a lot of uh interest
people interested in what we're doing
one way or another but it's not like
anything I say we leave it in for now
and if we want to discuss taking it out
the next meeting you
canil yeah I mean my whole point in like
saying what I was saying was that I know
lots of spa owners that sell sell creams
and I don't want to see them their
businesses hurt I want to see them still
be able to sell their creams and perhaps
uh if we can have some suggestive
language on to make sure we're not
inadvertently making some lawful
businesses that are operating lawfully
right now require licenses to make sure
we don't mess that
up in regards to accessories any issues
there Mr
chairman sorry sorry to take us back um
but I wanted to look up one section this
is on line 22 on page three back to the
de definition of illegal drug and so I
just looked up 318 B2 which is includes
the acts prohibited and so our list of
exceptions possession use manufacturer
sale is not fully inclusive of all the
things here like they have um have under
their control possessed with intent to
sell like I'm wondering if we should
just mirror the language to make sure
that all the exceptions are in
there that that makes sense no I agree
we want to have consistency so
so sorry to bring us back I just didn't
away now wouldn't we want to just kind
of what we did with um first definition
of definition of alternative treatment
centers we reference the RSA and then we
can cut and past that same
language does that make sense and what's
what's the what's the RSA you were
referencing
any problem with that from anyone any
objection I think it makes the language
so thank you in respect to accessories
Mr chairman just one quick comment and
and I'm not sure this is the correct
place to put it in but we have to make
sure that we have a lot of uh businesses
out there now that are selling
accessories that are not uh not going to
be levied the
15%
uh percentage that the The Liquor
Commission will ask for so I think what
we would want to do when we have when
and if we have our Outlets we want to
make sure that the revenues from the
accessories are not put into the to the
taxed portion of the revenue because I
think it would then be unfair to have
some people taxed on selling accessories
and others that are
not so I think that we would want to
make sure that the accessories in the
outlets when and if the language is pass
are exempt from the
fee other than that you'd have some
businesses in the state that are selling
those products that aren't being taxed
and some that
are anyone have any comment on
that I would agree with my colleague
that that would create an unfair um
burden upon businesses that are already
selling those
items so so I
think if you're let's just say you're
selling you know the the whatever pipes
and whatever that that's you want to
call that storm
right they they wouldn't be subject to
any franchise Fe so I guess the question
is if if a franchisee inside their store
elected to
sell the pipes or what whatever the
paraphernalia is would the stuff sold
inside the franchise store be subject to
the 15% royalty it shouldn't be I
agree it's just it's simply drawer one
and draw too in your POS system so if
you're selling paraphernalia items it's
not being taxed on the grand sale of
your retail you're just the Cannabis
items are being taxed other than that
you're creating an unfair Advantage for
the businesses that are in place now or
a disadvantage if you now choose to tax
them or Levy the franchise fee with
them Mr chairman do we know know how
other states are doing that like does
Massachusetts tax uh paraphernalia
that sorry repeat that I was just was
wondering how other states were handling
paraphernalia sold in their stores do we
know if they're imposing higher tax
burdens well
it I don't know what every State's doing
some states just have a general retail
sales tax my my thought was
the franchisee if you choose to buy your
paraphernalia from there you're already
there it's the choice of the consumer it
might be cheaper to go to another store
but I don't think the retail stores are
relying on their par parapan Alia cells
as their big money
maker
are come come to the microphone if you
don't mind just introduce yourself and
the
well hello uh in in in in in oh in Maine
right in our stores we sell clothing and
we do sell some paraphernalia although
it's not a big thing it's more of a
convenience thing we charge main sales
tax on on any cannabis product but we do
not CH charge main sales tax on any
paraphernalia any clothing and I believe
CBD products if it's just CBD but isn't
there a General like retail sales tax
10% so wouldn't that apply to the
paraphernalia uh it's it doesn't apply
to the if you come up to the counter and
you're buying from us and you have a
shirt you don't pay tax on the shirt but
if you if you buy flow you pay tax on
the flow so we tax them on the flower
but not on the shirt but take cannabis
out of it you go you go to a you know
any type of retail store isn't there a
broad-based sales tax oh okay yeah yes
the main sales tax I think is 6% so they
would pay but there's but the Cannabis
tax is not applied to it the Cannabis
tax but this the broad-based sales tax
would be applied correct if you have a
well New Hampshire doesn't have one but
in Maine yeah we charge 6% on top of
that but in Maine we charge 10% on
cannabis and then 6% the general sales
tax that's how it
works if I could uh just a two quick
comments Jim Riddle again um on your
definition I do believe I don't have it
in front of me but you include the word
license in that definition of
accessories
and currently stores sell accessories
without having to be licensed so I don't
know if that's an inadvertent inclusion
of a word or if you're thinking of
considering an entire paraphernalia
licensing
system so Mr chair if I may is it is
that correct the it does currently say
licens again to try to I tend to agree
with the fact that um we shouldn't be
charging a tax on on the on the produ on
the non cannabis products and so I think
number four I I didn't see anywhere we
actually have a license for a cannabis
accessory reseller anywhere in the bill
so I think that number four is probably
a leftover from somewhere else that did
have it so I think we should strike
number four and under I'm G to Jump
Ahead real
quick when it comes to striking number
four are we all okay with
that or anyone have any I'm not saying
you approve of BS but just or would be
cannabis accessory retail retailer means
an entity licensed to sell cannabis
accessories and paraphernalia yeah we
don't have a license for that anyway so
it doesn't matter so that's my point and
then just one final thing um on the
question of seeds uh being in the
definition of cannabis I will uh send to
you the DEA determination letter where
they specifically say seeds because they
don't contain THC are hemp and not
cannabis us regardless of their genetic
potential thank you the last thing I'd
say Mr chair when it comes to this
taxation this question is I'm going to
jump ahead real quick to page 18 where
we talk about Taxation and I think we
can just fix this by adding um the
franchise free on a uh sorry a franchise
fee on a monthly total gross revenue
less cannabis accessories and that
solves the problem we're not taxing
accessories at that point we're not we
Define What accessories are but we're
we're clearly saying that it's not a
taxable event whether you're a licensed
franchise or an individual that should
solve that problem I to step up
sure so do that make sense to everybody
so I made note We'll add that add that
in but so we're going to strike section
four we'll leave section three as it is
and we strike in a future language that
accessories are not going to be text
yeah and use the same terms right
cannabis ex yes yep use the same exact
that definition of three will be used
that that language in in the taxable
language all right moving on to number
five any question to discussion on
number five um Mr Vice chair yes I'm
wondering if
um uh do we are we gonna is the plan to
go through every definition or do we
want to go like the folks have comments
just step through and if nobody has any
common we quickly move past it right
just to make sure we we address so no
questions on number five no comments I
have a question Mr chairman I'm sorry
question yes Chief uh should we add uh
in five and actually some of the
subsequent paragraphs as well a lure
itself uh for example cannabis
facilitation uh cultivation facility or
cultivation facility means in entity
registered and add and licensed by the
state of New Hampshire or are we just
registering these
uh
Endeavors so I think
uh Mr mik we we talked those are light
LIC entities anyway so we could just
change register to the word license and
be done with it and that clarifies it
everybody okay with
that thank you so on number five line
eight at the end of that sentence we're
license any further discussion on
five seeing on moving on the number six
cannabis
establishment
any questions
here once again just just for
clarification do we need to be more
specific and indicate that such
establishments are licensed for example
again uh canab cannabis establishment
means any license to Hampshire cannabis
cultivation facility Etc do we want to
get that specific it it's included at
the end of that definition and licensed
commission but that's referen to the
last clause or any other type of
cannabis business license and commission
and license so that's just to that last
Clause so the am Li authorized am
license doesn't apply to the beginning
of the sentence we could add the words
uh
including something like that including
mean
so here's what here's what I'm going to
recommend so we don't have to do license
license license through this whole thing
for each one of these commas that are in
here um so what how how do you feel
about we just put a license establish I
mean a cannabis established means a
licensed and then I'll just number A B C
D for each one of the facilities so it
means that all of these things have to
be licensed that are in there because it
applies to all the sub paragraphs does
that make sense and just break that down
so it's clear that it has to be with
discuss a cannabis establish in this
chapter means anything anybody is
you and that clarifies
that number seven cannabis product
manufacturing facility or or product
definition and again I can do the ABCD
if you want on this one as well because
we do have a bunch of commas in there
there and to to Senator Whitley's
grammar police the license only apply to
the first to the first comma if I don't
put that if we don't modify I will say
that it came up because I'm teaching
statutory interpretation at the law
school and that issue about you know
what it applies to is deeply disgusted
the the other lawyer in the room is
nodding so we'll do the same thing we'll
do an ABCD on that one to talk about
each one of those you know license to a
purchase cannabis B uh the Manu B to
manufacture prepare package cannabis and
see to sell blah blah blah we'll do a
license a bullet point for each one of
those after the word license just to
make sure it's clarified that license
means all of these things not just the
first
comma I missed the I had no idea just
say
yes what did anyone else say by my
number doesn't
matter so we're moving on to number
eight um cannabis products all right
so all right I'm I'm back page four line
26 we're walking through the definitions
each one you're doing a good job keep
going so number eight Canabis products
um any questions on
those CBD
there last still not
include that way what you're doing is
you're making
it isn't CBD a cannabis extract am I
wrong when I say that I I believe it is
but we we have to definitely protect
these already established businesses
that that's why people in the I think
the easiest way to do that is to
um so what a cannabis extract is CBD oil
we can say keep the word Canabis extract
excluding so here's the interesting so
they have right this where we get into a
little detail about what a CBD and
certain concentrations we heard the
conversation ear talk about low potency
um products under 0.0 under 3% right is
low potency product and not considered
to be cannabis for the purposes of a lot
of other statutes um but above that
threshold is considered to be um a
cannabis product and so how we Define
that might be interesting in here so if
we want to talk about low potency and
create a definition for that so that we
can say that low potency products are or
not regulated um I'm not sure how we
want to deal with that but again the
Delta 9 Delta 8 Delta 10 THC products
that can be derived out of C CBD oil
right through a chemical process and
have potency within a CBD product that
problematic so there's a gentleman in
the audience that wants to speak and
that hold on a second if you can
approach the
microphone that would be and just say
one of the things that we noticed when
we were reviewing this and then I heard
today you're talking about potency of
low potency of like 10% I'm growing a
plant right so I send a plant into the
lab to test and and first of all 10% not
even realistic we don't even grow 10%
strains anymore okay but let's say it's
it's above you know what you guys put is
the potency what am I supposed to do
destroy it or run it into oil I you know
I can't do that it's not like we tell
the plant how much THC is going to be in
it when it comes out the end and we have
it tested but I can assure you 10% is
not close to where where you have to be
work well I but I think the definition
here is to what we're going to exclude
from the definition especially after
manufacturer right so so again it's
about after manufacturer um what we're
going to exclude from the definition
correct so all right Dr
so question the vice chair was saying
are we are we talking about low potency
cannabis products or are we talking
about hemp and I think we need to be
careful about not interchanging them so
if it's less than3 THC then it's hemp if
it's greater than that then it's maybe a
low potency product until we get to
another threshold but if we put the
definition of what is considered to be
hemp and um maybe that would take care
of
that
right so we if we add a sentence
basically anything that's you know
currently under definition of hen shall
not be falling this
definition it might be too broad but I
think airing on the side of caution not
require every lighting store to get a
license that's going to take right but I
don't think I mean it's it currently you
technically if if everything is as
marketed on a container you can't get
you can't get something that's above 3%
currently outside of an ATC so if you
went to the co-op and bought it there
there shouldn't be at least what's
currently on the label rather or not
that tests out as different but um I
just wonder if if we don't we're not
specific it seems like it could be a
problem any any
recommendation we're not going to hold
you to we know putting you on the spot
yeah no I mean I think that point if
point three is what the federal
government Rec recognizes we put that
there very specifically then that should
in theory cover everything that's
legally being sold in retail stores
currently so doctor would you mind
taking this as a homework project and
rewrite this definition and bring it
back to the next meeting so we can take
a look at it and and evaluate it don't
be leaving home
or and we definitely just want to make
sure we protect those uh
yep so so Dr yunen will expect next
meeting have something to revie
that um next up is cannabis retail Chief
I may have lost my I may have lost my
place I apologize uh we still on uh
paragraph seven uh eight rather yeah we
just we just the doctor was going to do
a review of what low potency means and
that kind of thing to make sure whether
it's covered or not covered as a
cannabis product I'm just wondering if
there's a reason to include Edibles in
deleted so my guess is that as we look
further on that we're going to have a
definition of what's eligible to sell
and I think Edibles are going to be one
of those definitions so we don't include
in the definition of what a cannabis
product is it would be excluded from the
sale process later on down the
you again well let I'm sure the doctor
who deals with that kind of language on
a regular basis will address it
accordingly in her definition so moving
on to number nine cannabis retail store
and I will say I have an issue with this
one and it's only because it's also in
relation to
number 16 we have two different
definitions I thought we were
consistently saying that an ATC if it
wants to open a franchise store be
separate from um the medical distribut
medical
dispensary and so I'm not sure why we
have two different they have we are in
the Bill we're allowing in the turn to
for-profit which would allow them to
become a franchise store
but the franchise store has to be
separate and distinct from the medical
store so we don't have a deal of
Taxation issues and two masters with two
agencies controlling the same facility
um and so I thought we were clear on
that so I'm not sure why we have two
different definitions I will tell you
well this was may have been written
before that right things have things
have evolved since this began its
circulation but my understanding is so
the alternative treatment centers they
have the choice they can remain as
they're operating now if they wish to
engage in the retail Market they can
choose to do so but to have both signs
on the store and just trying to figure
that out it's not not going to work well
I agree and that's why we don't have two
different definitions right we have a
definition that's you're either a retail
store and you're following the controls
and conditions of the of the Liquor
Commission or you're a dispensary your
medical dispensary in which you fall
under controls and conditions of DHHS
and there's no two masters was involved
and who's regulating signage who's
regulating labeling who's regulating um
all of that those two so my
recommendation is to strike number nine
and on number 16 strike the last
sentence and that allows the the
uh ATC to become a dispense become a
franchise store if they choose to they
can either um they can open a separate
location with a separate that's all
under controls the conditions of the
liquor store I support
that
and so so we striking number nine
altoe and striking the last sentence of
number 16 that they're not prohibited
from becoming a LIC page five 11 line 11
and 12 there was also an issue that
number N9 had the can's paraphernalia in
there again so that would have been
large so all right anyone have an issue
with what striking paragraph 9 and then
good number 10 cannabis testing facility
or testing
facility so this was what I was talking
about before if we want the state to run
the testing facility themselves or we
want a private facility we can have a
little bit of both I don't know I don't
I Know Chief you suggested that the
state is capable of doing it that also
means we the state would absorb the
expense if it was private and you
required the franchises to do it that
would perhaps pass the expense on it and
doesn't mean the state couldn't come in
and do some testing as a kind of an
oversight capacity but I see our our
friend from Maine who and jumping and uh
someone who's appeared testified about
times thank you Mr chairman for the
record again Matt Simon Granite LEF
cannabis just a brief comment on how
other states have dealt with this there
are currently no states that how do you
recommend what's your recommendation
I'll jump to the chase my recommendation
would be a system that relies on private
testing labs and the option would be to
have a State Testing Lab that audits the
private testing Labs so this is the
issue that they had in Vermont there
weren't enough testing labs and a
product did make it to the shelf that
hadn't been tested the state didn't have
its own lab and the ability to recall
that product and test it it also provid
provides oversight in case there's an
issue with the lab maybe not providing
accurate test results this is a way for
the state to immediately be able to test
a product itself and spot check to make
sure the independent labs are doing it
thank you your our friend from Maine is
shaking his head yes which means he
likes what you
said so question uh Chief do you have
that not holding it to I just I mean
does that no again we would we would
strongly recommend State uh but I
suppose if there has to be a compromise
that might be a viable
one so basically the state would be able
to audit any results and they could even
perform their own test if they chose to
do so but it's passed on to a private
business is that look I have any any
that I I think that the best way to do
it it it would be to have private Labs
tested and if we wanted to have a backup
system in place that the state would do
it but we would need to we certainly
would need to talk to the department we
don't want C two things I I think from a
business standpoint we don't want it to
be cumbersome for the product to get to
Market uh so if it's an
alternative then we would be in favor of
that but I I certainly don't want
to yeah we don't want to speak for the
Department of Safety because obviously
that would be the labbing that would be
the lab facility that would do the
testing so you know I don't think we
would want to talk about what testing
the department of St we also want to
overburden the Department of safety's
Labs testing this versus yeah correct Mr
going back to the definition I think
this allows for that either a state run
model or an a third party independent
model and would also depending on the
regulations when we get into the testing
which I think is in here um it would
allow for either the liquor to require
you know to say we're going to take this
product and we're go to a different
testing facility licensed testing
facility have them test the product to
verify the first testing I think again
that's going to fall underneath the
regulation aspect of this and not
necessarily the legal aspect of the law
aspect right um it's going to be in
regulatory requirements and and M Matt
Simon if you don't mind you mentioned a
what another state did I think Vermont
if you can provide the commission that
appreciated but I bet you're well
definition next up is number 11 cannabis
transporter any conversations around
here again this is um a licensed
entity
so
if if you're an ENT if you're an entity
right that's cultivating but you're also
you're transport to your own retail
store you have to have a separate
license to transport it from one to the
other
yes specifically for transporting can
cannabis one involves a DOT right over
what's that do it's over the
highways well again I think I think the
idea behind here is about um again in
every step of the process we have
control and licensure happening so
there's no unregulated unlicensed part
that's happening in between so from the
time you go to cultivation you move it
to manufacturing the person that moves
it from cultivation to manufacturing
must be licensed unless it's assume it
could be within the same facility if the
cultivator also had a manufacturing
license you're moving it from building
to building and that's on your own
property you'd be okay but if you had to
move it from Kean to Portsmith for
manufacturing then that Transportation
would require that person would need to
be licensed and then if you're moving it
from the manufacturing facility to the
to the retail store again that person
would have license so you have a
complete closed loop on on from from
seed to
sale I was getting at the point if
you're
a cultivator and a manufacturer and you
want to ship it to the stores you you
get an additional license now
transporter even if you're also the
retailer you so you're basically I know
it I know there's separate entities
sometimes but it's it's same guys
operating everything
right they couldn't have I guess a
manufacturer or a Heth can't have an
in-house Mr chairman I don't think it
needs to become a burdensome um process
of Licensing I think to to the Senator's
point it's just that seed to sale
process and where the product is going
and I would I would also add that from
our standpoint from a retail standpoint
for the state we would want to make sure
that the manufacturers and The Growers
had the ability to do this to keep the
costs
down and I know with with alcohol we
have a really good system in place when
it comes to distribution so we have one
distribution system one
Warehouse when it comes to when it comes
to
definition number 12 commission means in
the hampsh Laker
commission wor with that all right that
was an easy one um number 13
consumer any discussion around the
seeing none
well um there was one discussion I we
had somewhat off record but if we had
the retail product and rather than have
separate atcs they have their branded
product and they could then have we
could create an opportunity where they
can sell their therapeutic gr product in
any retail store if that franchise he
wanted to adopt that policy if we did
that
um it would be sold only to people have
the therapeutic
car so you're talking about mixing
medical into the retail store so let's
let's say let's say all the atc's be be
adopted opted in a granted a franchise
from the state uh the issue is is their
branding would essentially he says from
a storefront go away but they still have
the products that they're manufacturing
and cultivating right now I presume they
would likely continous sells out of
their own now retail store but what
happens to the therapeutic system the
idea is you can still have therapeutic
grade products but then maybe permit
them to any franchise be allowed to sell
them provided the person had the
therapeutic car it it does you don't
want to have the unfair marke Advantage
where some franchises have therapeutic
products and some
don't but we want
to so again this goes to the comingling
of regulatory requirements right so my
inclination was anybody who chooses
again it's a choice to put up a retail
store be subject to the rules and
regulations and conditions of the Liquor
Commission and so if the Liquor
Commission approves this moving of their
product into that into that store again
all The Branding and labeling is subject
to The Liquor Commission correct and and
the
therapeutic the atcs would then fall
under the regulation of of liquor as
well store operations would fall
underneath liquor not their medical
distribution proper no as it's written
that's that's what you're right I'm
asking I'm proposing that we I don't
want to cross Bingle that does our folks
in the atcs have any comment as they sit
together you don't mind uh taking the
mic I'm I'm just saying in that case
it's it's going to be sold out other
sense I'm sorry Mr chairman I'm still
not clear on the question you're asking
here so if rather than your stores
remaining keeping their own identity on
a storefront basis you still have the
products that that you your therapeutic
products correct now those have their
own brand ID identity as well correct
those products if each of your respected
establishments became a retail store it
would have to have the New
Hampshire franchisee logo and that's it
and I'm what I'm suggesting is if you
still want to sell your therapeutic
grade products which I my understanding
is you do uh it does somewhat result in
unfair Market Advantage if only certain
retail stores are able to sell the
therapeutic great
products I would think it would be to
the atc's benefit if all the retail
stores had opportun to sell the products
that you atc's could exclusively
manufacture but at the same time if we
went that direction you I think it would
make sense for a lot of the oversight
and enforcement regulation to fall under
the Liquor Commission not
DHHS uh with that being said if we went
that direction which is the direction I
would like to go not sure if my friend
to my left agrees I'm not sure how
everyone else feels about that
it how does the atcs feel about that
well as we said last week we do have a
strong preference to be able to operate
dual use locations we understand that's
a policy choice for the commission and
for ultimately for the general court um
there are a number of policy questions
kind of rolled into one here uh we would
like to be able to expand access to
patients so they don't have to drive to
one of seven locations it would be
beneficial for patients if they could
purchase their at cannabis at any store
um the only question is how to provide
the education and support services that
particularly firsttime patients and
making their initial purchases would
need there are some gaps that we think
would need to be filled and we think
those gaps can be filled um but in terms
of whether it's a unfair advantage or or
disadvantage I mean we're not talking
about a huge Market here we're talking
about 13,000 registered patients a
number that's likely to decline after
adult use so in part there is an
advantage being able to serve both
markets but it's also a bit of a
disadvantage or at least a burden that
we would be required to continue serving
patients and making for example small
batches of products that aren't really
financially lucrative so it's kind of a
mix of advantages and disadvantages I
would suggest no one's requiring the
atcs to sell to other stores that that's
again that's a business decision left to
be made by each of you respectfully and
one of you may choose to do it some of
you may not but I think the issue is
when it comes to defining consumer I
thought if you did that it's you know
you're going to have other Revenue
sources from cultivation but I would
like to see if that's for Consumer
definition wise we may not want to have
a distinction between the two for the
purposes of this
chapter sure so if I may provide a
hopefully relatively simple answer
answer is that generally the regulations
between adult use and medical are very
similar in Most states and I would
expect them to be extremely similar here
if not able to be made identical so I
would hope that there' be limited
barriers to the opportunity of doing
doable again
so my concern is is a dual use single
store is problematic for both regulatory
reasons as well as taxation reasons
about what what products are are not
taxed and which drawer do you put the
money in um I mean all kinds of basic
functional problems that I think it's
hard for liquor to be able to deal with
the Dual use single store um I was clear
I I supported dual again atcs or atc's
retail stores or retail stores separate
models separate regulatory models
separate regulatory agencies that deal
with that that does not prohibit um an
at see who may have a strain of product
they want to offer in the retail store
to be able to do that however the
labeling and testing would be subject to
the rules and conditions that that uh
the liquor store would put on it so you
can move product a you know you grow a
whole bunch of product a and you'll use
a section of it for um for your medical
distribution but then you also go to
liquor and say I want to approve have
this product approved for the sale in
the retail store you can sell that in
your own retail store or you can offer
it for all retail stores again that's up
to you based on your private model that
you would have so you may have um
product a in retail store one but you
don't own retail store 2 so therefore
you're not making it available to retail
store two and that's your competitive
Advantage is the product that's
available in the med in the medical
could also be available in the in your
retail store for you to manage so I
think that's the competitive Advantage
but I do not want to enter into a situ I
don't want to enter into a situation
about who's the controlling Authority in
a given square footage of a building
based on Dual use in a single space so I
think we're
basically it's not going to if you're
going to do retail you know I don't
think selling therapeutic in either
going to be sold in all the retail
stores or none of them that's up to them
that
said well I think that they rather sell
in all of them than none of them I
assume so again they can apply a lottery
for their flower a product to be
available in all retail stores or they
can say I only want to do it in my
private store as as I'm sure the rest of
the commission is enjoying this healthy
discussion Senator Lang and I are having
does anyone else have any comment on I
want to join the healthy discussion U
representative kale I'm always up for a
healthy discussion I I'm kind of
wondering what what the commission the
proposed commission thinks are are they
um are they game for maybe uh taking
over um control over the th and
completely removing it from
DHHS
well I don't think they're going to
preference are they are they capable of
doing it I guess is the
question we're certainly capable of
doing it as far as having a
preference I don't think we have a
preference on it I would say the other
part part of that is that even ATC
products would essentially be part of
the franchise fee but I we have to I'm
not sure if the business side of that
make sense if if you distribute to the
other stores depends on how many stores
are are and your cultivation I think
making it easier to to account for
everything rather than having
separate draw is
that yeah uh just one comment uh Brandon
Pollock with tascal Wellness One the
atc's in so far as an operational
perspective it's not our policy choice
but from an operational perspective if
accessories for example or paraphernalia
will not be subject to a franchise fee I
think a therapeutic product would have
no additional issues of that sort of
structure I mean I definitely think our
goal as as as as a committee should be
able to keep the cost for the
therapeutic users as low as we possibly
can I understand that my concern is when
it comes to a franchise agreement if you
don't have the 15% at the beginning I'm
not really clear you're going to be able
to add it down the line in a responsible
way so it's kind of now and never and
from what it sounds like the therapeutic
industry is going to might get smaller
and smaller and smaller I'm not saying
go away completely but it might become a
very minor sector of the market and at
that point you're going to have all
these therapeutic products people what
happens in Massachusetts there's like a
20% sales tax which is very high you can
spend $300 a or I don't know if that's
the exact price for a license a medical
card or whatever they call it and you're
exempt from that tax
all the way for the rest of the year you
also get to cut the line and have your
own register it gets around the revenue
side of things so one thing that could
happen is that the therapeutic side can
kind of readjust its policies and be get
a larger market share it's going to cut
into the franchise fee and rather than
have those competing interests it seems
we're going to essentially Grant valid
on manufacturing the higher therapeutic
grade stuff but it's not going to
overtake or really diminish the
franchise model it seems like everyone's
kind of getting in a good position there
but if you don't do the 15% now or
whatever we whatever that franchise feed
is determined to be adding it in three
years from now five years from now I
don't know if that's legal appropriate
fair business model so if you're going
to do it you want to do it now not later
opinion let everyone know what they're
getting into we don't have to answer
this today it's
again this is good discussion imagine if
we didn't do it now then three years
from now we decided to add 15% you're
going to be looking at us like where're
how how how could we so I think it's
important to know what the commitment is
and and let us know business-wise
perhaps maybe the next meeting comment
on that sure I would just suggest there
are other stakeholders who'd be
interested in this in this policy choice
and certainly patients would would
object to a tax or fee being imposed
that would apply to them that does not
currently the the fee is paid by the the
franchisee you know how you adjust your
prices to the consumer you can really
take care of the patients you know
you're going to have to judge that any
way you can um and that's why I'm asking
does the business sense make sense
remember you guys are going to make
money off cultivation
sales to to all the retail stores that
are out there there's other Revenue that
can be made as well so I think it's
hopefully that should keep the price
down
too but okay
move on from consumer we'll come back to
Consumer definition um Department means
the Department of Health and Human
Services number
14 any discussion there we're good well
do do we do we want to completely remove
DHHS completely from any control over
over well I think later on in the in the
bill we have some conversations where
DHHS might have some stuff around Labs
or some other testing and lab some other
component so I think that's the only
reason and there again we need a
definition if we talk about the we talk
about the commission we talk about the
Lottery Commission we say Department
we're talking about the Department of
Services number 14 we addressed are
there any other uh so we struck we
agreed to strike the last line last
sentence is there any other changes to
number 14 or 16
rather Mr chairman chief on 16 uh in
light of some of the testimony we heard
earlier today we'd like to recommend
that uh this refer only to in-person
sales that it not be online sales or
nature does anyone have any any comment
on
that uh you can make an online sale of
Dunkin Donuts but you got to show up to
up so that that needs to be addressed
Chief when you say no online sales
you're talking about online and
delivered by a third party
sales yeah okay you could still you
could still uh order it order it online
but you have to pick it up but you have
to be picked up or yeah I tend to I I
agree with that I could live with that
so what are we looking for a CH where
where do you want to put the change at
the bottom or the the end of 16 okay
what do you want it would just say
inperson sales only or we could be more
specific with the online but the whole
idea is just to make sure that people
aren't you know again in L of uh in
reference to the earlier testimony about
the difficulties that for example Maine
was having with online or not in person
and being able to identify themselves as
an individual capable of buying I mean
people do that with alcohol all the time
now they're buying it and miners are
buying it uh online and what have you so
so the question one thing I want to be
careful of is if it extra if it ex if
the program expends extends to the point
where I could go online and order it but
I have to go in person to pick it up
pick it up right so it allows for online
ordering but in
person um distribution
sure I agree with that I I think
um we certainly not there yet if that
policy is Revisited by Future
legislators but I think out of the gate
you got to come in person that's just
that's that's what I'm talking to we TR
to make it clear that's the situation so
it's not it's not yeah I mean one of the
things I I I was in I was in uh New
Orleans and they literally have
dispensary District um Ubers that
deliver your drugs for you right
certainly do and so I want to make sure
the Hampshire doesn't become that I
yeah all
right all right so number um 17 and I
guess I have a question on 17 and 19 is
why would define youone an immature and
a mature plan is if we're not dealing
with cultivation anywhere else in there
for hom growth I'm not sure we re
utilize this language anywhere else and
I I'd recommend striking number 17 and
that as we go through this uh please
look for any unintended consequences by
striking those if you see any other
references to mature immature plants but
I agree striking it's
inflation did we go to The Possession
limits well we're we're above it we're
in between this
one KN glasses walking through so I'm
not sure where this is used in the
chapter I don't know why we have a
definition of inflation but um I guess I
don't I'm withhold comment until I see
where else it's used in the bill I
didn't see it anywhere but if it's not
maybe we can strike it
but yeah and if we didn't Define
inflation in this chapter it's it's it's
already defined by when you say
inflation it has legal definition so it
can be I think we'll take it out for now
in the interest of trying to keep this
under 100 pages and if we need to put it
back in we understand where to find it
number 20 municipality means the city
town or an unincorporated place again I
think this is rela to we use
municipalities for two purposes further
on in the statute we talk about who can
authorize you know the the zoning and
regul Regulatory stuff as well as we
allow for some of the fees collected by
municipality number 21 any other comment
we good there any uh 21 how late we
going there how long you want to
go I I can I I mean I can be here till 7
o' but I see no one else want I'm not
sure we're going to go that far but
how's how's everyone doing so far
everyone's brain's working good all
right so number 21 possession
limit cheap left on the most important
part well I so I I I did talk speak
privately and you know I'm not going to
hold this to any any or we have another
Chief
here could would that person perhaps
are we allowed to do that sure
yeah any problem with the chief
replacement introduce
yourself he's probably ready to go he
probably ate lunch
already like the rest of us certainly my
name is Pat Sullivan I'm the executive
director for the Chiefs Association I'm
also retired Chief from
gwn and thank you for joining us um
possession limits my understanding is um
there's some disagreement on that I know
uh for cannabis products it says what's
us so this is The Possession limits that
not preserving it's if how much you have
it but how many 5.5 milligram squares of
candy bars can one person legally own in
once
okay yeah how many of those candy bars
then can you have is the question if
there if I want to walk into the store
and buy every single candy bar and gummy
off the shelf I would probably even
exceed the
uh uh the uh 2,000 milligrams I'm saying
is how much am I legally allowed to
possess without violating the law I is
it unlimited is it no it's it's not uned
have this say 4 ounces for flour 20
grams of concentrated
then M Mr chair does this possession um
definition apply to people that are
transporting it for
manufacturers it wouldn't because that
that would be this is this is your
consumer right this goes back to the
consumer definition so this is the
person who walks in the store if they
exceed a certain amount are they now
eventually in violation of the
law and I guess the question
is so let's start with a right is
everybody okay with a there any
definition of a that's different
Chief we're looking with a for 2 ounces
of marijuana in the Cannabis or excuse
me cannabis in the plant form so it's
list four but we would go we we think
two would be acceptable and reasonable I
I think airing on the side of less is a
good idea and the gentleman from Maine
our friend from Maine just said that
that uh two is what main he believed
what
main I ask a different question what
what do we just set for a limit on
decriminalization possession of how much
75 I believe 75 Bal 75 of an oun
commission yeah I mean just a couple
things to flag here I mean I I think we
would definitely prefer to keep it at
four and I think if you look at this in
the context of alcohol for example I can
go in and buy as much whiskey as I want
to buy and I think it's import the other
important thing to remember is we have
sales laws on the books and so if you if
someone has 4 ounces and they're caught
selling outside of the authorization
this legislation they can be prosecuted
for that because they're going outside
the bounds but this is just personal
possession I think we should that's
totally fine to have 4 ounces um and if
they're doing something illegal with
that 4 ounces then there are multiple
ways under current law for that person
to be held accountable but I think it's
just it's it's odd to kind of have that
limit here but then with alcohol which
is I think objectively more dangerous we
have no no limits at all you can buy you
know cases and cases and cases of
whiskey without without concern so I
just wanted to add I was just looking up
what what Massachusetts is doing um you
know to add to Maine and saying 1 ounce
of flour five grams of concentrate
compared to 20 we have here and 500
milligrams of Edibles um versus 2,000
milligrams what was what was the last
one 500 yeah so it was 1 ounz of flour 5
gram of concentrate and 500 milligrams
so I I would go with the 2 O myself if
that's what our some of our surroundings
are again you have remember we're
dealing with people who may come from
Massachusetts to New Hampshire and have
more than the 3/4 of an ounce possession
limit we have now so I think erroring on
the side of caution I think we we adjust
to two it keeps it consistent with Maine
uh semi consistent with Massachusetts um
and so we don't have these tourists that
are coming in that are becoming
accidental criminals because of their
possession limit in their state slightly
more than a possession limit in our
state if I could ask our good friends
some mean one
question you can point at someone else
but realistically when a consumer comes
in the store how often do they buy what
a consumer and I'm just just speculating
how often do they actually buy The
Possession
limit I'm sorry if if someone's going to
speak to the commission they should
speak into the microphone just for the
uh uh what was the question
again I in your in your experience I
understand that you're speculating or
making an estimate how often do
consumers come into the store in Maine
which has 2 and a half ounce flow limit
yeah how often a consumer is actually
purchasing that 2 and a half ounce limit
well first of all we don't sell it in
ounces right 80% of what we sell we sell
in 1/8 ounce jars so you know an eigh
ounce jar is about 40 bucks retail okay
so how much do they we do it on how much
they normally spend we have two ATMs in
there and we Trace everything and it it
averages about $80 a customer is there
people that go in there and spend 500 or
700 bucks yeah they're they're
absolutely is you know but generally
speaking the average customer is
spending $80 out of out of customers how
much would you say are going to buy well
give me a level to spend more than $200
and a visit no this has to do with the
amount you not how much money you're
spending it's the amount you you can
legally possess all right if it's 4
ounces it's higher than Maine but if we
made it two and a half like main I'm
just asking as we debate whether it
should be 2 ounces three four whatever
I'm just asking how often is someone
coming in even buying that large of a
amount of flower uh on a reg on a
regular basis you know it happens a lot
especially because we're we're um in an
area where there's a lot of vacationers
and they're not necessarily in legal
states so they come and they they'll buy
stuff to bring home with them so you
know so it's it's a reg for somebody to
spend $2 $300 I'd say two or three an
hour do that someone to spend
$500 few a few one every few few days
someone to spend $1,000 I don't think
I've ever seen that I've never seen
that Mr chair again I'm just looking for
consistency across the board in our
medical cannabis program it's 2 ounces
so it's it creates a consistent law
across the board whether in a medical or
in regulatory you have a 2 ounce limit
of possession but this stuff is stronger
higher potency than what the consumer
product we have no idea what the
consumer product looks like yet we
well again in in our law from what I'm
looking at it says a patient can possess
no more than two ounces of
of it says unusable which I don't
understand why but a
cannabis but um again it's 2 ounces for
the purposes of plant material in our in
our statute and that's usually a law
enforcement views it is in ounces and
pounds and kilos what what is the price
of 2 ounces of of product don't sell
okay could we do a conversion a an e
ounce jars well it's 40 for an A so
that's three 320 for an ounce but again
it's not the same as buying volum buy
different JS
different so 320 an ounce so you're
looking at 640 you just said maybe one
person a week would spend 640 so $640 an
320 the black market would take over the
industry if they sold at that
less all right so my so Mr chair on on
11 Dave I think we just we just heard
from the medical experts and uh they
talk about how youth are getting the
product and they're getting it from
people people buying marijuana for them
I think we should be below a better
where somebody can't go place an order
and go buy it for for youth I think it
makes more sense from a public health
standpoint so mass is one main is two I
think Main's two and a half two and a
half and our our medical is two so my
recommendation would be we change a to 2
ounces B to five grams and C to 500
milligrams the last two at the doctor's
recommendation and I think that that
keeps consistency across our laws can I
I with Senator L all right I from a
public listen I understand that I just
want one thing to be considered here and
I've asked this question and I never can
get an answer but I'm ask it again in
the prior Recreation bills I would see
it had like I think it said 1 ounce I
forget what it said for grams whatever
these stores are only selling limited
products and in New Hampshire we make a
lot of our sales and Retail comes
from out ofate consumers buying in bulk
I think our liquor sales is a large
percentage go to out of state now I
don't think I maybe 4 ounces is too much
but I'm s part of a lot of the consumer
models in retail not even reference to
just cannabis relies on people coming
here whether it's for vacation or coming
over the board in the weekend and buying
in bulk so and the these numbers here
which I you when I put together 1598 was
kind of throwing them around Loosely
explaining that part of the revenue
model is that we sell a lot the a ofate
consumers now if you only can buy a
certain amount I was concerned that a
private retailer is that even enough for
them to stay in business if they only
can sell one ounce or two ounces no one
seems to know the answer for that so if
the business is going to rely on the
franchisee model relies on the out of
state consumers buying in bulk I mean we
have have to make it even now that
doesn't mean we open the floodgates and
make it 4 ounces but by making it two
five and 500 are we limiting our our I
guess hurting the franchise
model that's a loaded that's a very
loaded question I just ask so now I'm
not saying it's responsible to make it
what it is today what it says here for
that's that's a large amount but but if
we if the system's not going to be
viable the franchise model because we
lose the bulk
happens I think having the fail systems
amount which is why these numbers be
when I put these large numbers together
as you can tell I'm not really a fan of
the numbers but the idea was to make the
system viable in Max your outstate sales
and I think liquor out ofate sales is
I understand that this is a tough pill
to swallow for some of us I you
understand the pl that I'm making I'm
not saying and I so I think there's a
lot to consider here we're also almost
at 1:30 we've been here since 10: no
one's eaten lunch so maybe we need to
settle on that question just percolate a
little bit
more and everyone's giving me a ster
like I'm crazy I mean well right I think
people are tired I am I'm hungry there's
only so much we can ask commissioners
just finish we'll just finish everyone's
uh I agree with my colleague a good
friend uh uses the halt hungry know
tired
yeah so suggesting s when he hungry
tired and angry or just I mean I think
this is an important question we want I
would like to percolate on it a little
bit more maybe we kind of rest on that
Friday is everyone good on Friday the
third I I have a call in the morning but
you guys I'm sure would love to care
about me you talk about the third yeah
oh I don't have that I don't have that
in my calendar but I think the senator
was mentioning that there's a conflict
would
third so we're doing a third at 10
o'clock
okay so we're going to stop on we're
going to stop on possession limit
everyone go home think about it come
back uh Chief uh uh uh commissioner de
Miker if you could just take a look at
the to the chair's point of how does
bulk sales impact your idea of a model
and what that looks like so we can have
that part of the discussion whether
increasing possession limits for the pur
purposes of sale um I what that looks
like and come back with that on a
revenue model what that might be and
then Dave remember you're bringing chap
that section three of the funding
formula to talk about alcohol the
Alcohol and Other Drug fund for
treatment and the doctor you have your
homework
assignment and with that we're
adjourned cultivation and Manufacturing
retail licenses on this you need to give
should